Diese Klänge dürften euch mittlerweile eigentlich bekannt vorkommen. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, 26. März 2008. Das heißt, wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat ist es Zeit für das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Vom Chaos Computer Club sind hier Frank, guten Abend. Dann haben wir heute zu Gast Markus Bekedahl von netzpolitik.org. Hallo. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir werden in den kommenden zwei Stunden um Filesharing und Überfilesharing reden. Sicherlich auch anhängend an das letzte große Halbapplausklatschen, was vor zwei Wochen zu hören war, als das Bundesverfassungsgericht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, über die wir an dieser Stelle sehr oft und sehr lange und ausführlich geredet haben, zumindest teilweise gekippt oder aber entschärft hat. Kann man so schon mal stehen lassen Frank, oder? Also der Stand der Dinge, der Stand der Dinge bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also dass die Anbieter von Telekommunikation, eure Kommunikationsdaten sechs Monate lang speichern müssen und auf Wunsch herausgeben. Es ist mittlerweile so, dass sie weiterhin speichern, allerdings diese Daten nur rausgegeben werden dürfen, wenn wirklich schwere und schwerste Straftaten im Verzug sind. Und damit der Hauptinteressent an diesen Daten, nämlich die Musikindustrie, ein kleines bisschen nese ist, weil Musik runterladen nicht gleich zu setzen ist mit Bomben basteln oder aber Terrorismus, wenn man es volkstimlich mal so formulieren mag. Und damit sind wir beim Thema der heutigen Sendung, nämlich Filesharing in Zeiten von Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Co. Welche Erfahrungen habt ihr gemacht? Habt ihr schon mal Sachen aus dem Netz besorgt? Geht ihr durch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung anders im Netz um? Bewegt ihr euch nicht mehr in Tauschbörsen? Habt ihr vielleicht schon mal von einem Anwalt Post bekommen, der sagt, sie haben an dem und dem Tag dann und dann Dateien ins Netz gestellt oder aber aus dem Netz geladen? Und welche Erfahrungen habt ihr gemacht? Und wie geht ihr damit um? Darüber können wir heute gerne reden. Unter der 0331 70 97 110. Und wir werden natürlich auch ein kleines bisschen die Hintergründe dieser ganzen Geschichte beleuchten. Wie kommt es eigentlich dazu, dass irgendjemand mich im Netz findet und weiß, dass ich irgendwann mal Musik aus dem Netz angeblich geladen haben soll? Darüber werden wir heute reden. Wir freuen uns sehr über eure Anrufe und damit sind wir beim eigentlichen Thema.
Ja, schön. Dazu gab es vor ja gut zwei Wochen in Karlsruhe eine Eilsentscheidung, eine Eilentscheidung, wo die also gesagt haben, okay, wir werden jetzt nicht in der Hauptsache entscheiden, sondern es gab da also einen Antrag, quasi erstmal vorläufig was zu machen. Das heißt also vorläufig was zu entscheiden. Darf jetzt weiter gespeichert werden? Wie dürfen die Daten verwendet werden? Gericht hat also gesagt, okay, wir brauchen jetzt noch ein bisschen Bedenkzeit. Das ist also keine endgültige Entscheidung. Aber wir machen so eine Abwägung der allen Interessen und sagen, okay, es darf erst mal weiter gespeichert werden. Aber die Daten dürfen nicht für irgendwelche Lappalen verwendet werden, sondern es muss wenn dann wirklich ganz klar um irgendwelche ganz konkreten Sachen gehen. Schwerste Verbrechen, Terrorismus. Da haben also viele Leute erst mal aufgeatmet, haben gesagt, okay, super. Jetzt können also die Provider, dürfen jetzt nicht mehr die Daten rausgeben an, zum Beispiel Firmen, die Urheberrechtsverletzungen, Musik im Internet verfolgen wollen. Weil das ist einfach ganz klar keine Straftat, die jetzt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht da reinbezogen wurde.
Wobei es trotz aller Demonstration ist festzuhalten nicht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwie mit dem Tenor rausgehen, boah, alles nicht so schlimm, wir können weiterhin irgendwie im Netz alles plündern. Was geht ist, bleibt weiterhin eine Urheberrechtsverletzung, damit ist es strafbar und damit, wenn ihr irgendwo Songs aus dem Netz saugt, nehmt ihr natürlich auch Künstlern, die die einzige oder eine der wenigen Einnahmequellen, die sie haben.
Das würde ich jetzt mal so nicht unterschreiben.
Wobei wir natürlich auch noch mal festhalten wollen, haben uns also auch ganz viele darum gebeten zu sagen, also Tauschbörsen sind nicht primär oder nicht nur nicht ausschließlich dazu da, um illegal Musik zu tauschen, sondern sind vor allem dazu da, um Daten zu verteilen, vor allem auch Software, gerade die großen Linux-Distributionen, also wenn man das jetzt auf einer CD bekommt, installiert, was ja eine freie Software ist. Dafür eignen sich so eine Tauschbörsensysteme wunderbar. BitTorrent, aber auch Edunkey und verschiedene Systeme sind wunderbar dazu da, Daten im Netz auszutauschen, Daten, die einfach alle haben sollen. Und auch gerade Künstler, die freie Musik anbieten, bedienen sich auch sehr gerne diesem System. Insofern, also es ist keine Schwarz-Weiß-Geschichte, sondern bei Tauschbörsen muss man noch mal schauen, genau was passiert da. Tatsache ist natürlich auch, da brauchen wir glaube ich auch keinen Hehl draus machen, dass Tauschbörsen schon im großen Teil auch genutzt werden, um einfach urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material oder beschränktes Material, wo die rechte Inhaber eben ein Problem damit haben, wenn es frei verfügbar ist im Netz, werden dafür benutzt. Ganz klare Sache. Und gut, ob es jetzt eine Lapalle ist oder eine schwere Straftat oder eine mittelschwere Straftat, denke ich, können wir heute Abend nicht diskutieren. Das ist auch gar nicht die Sache. Das ist nicht das Thema. Klar, es ist ein Risiko dabei. Irgendwie bei vielen Leuten fährt die Angst mit. Ich habe mal gesagt, es ist so ein bisschen wie Schwarzfahren. Es machen halt ganz viele Leute und meistens geht es auch gut.
Man hofft immer, dass man selber nicht erwischt wird, ja.
Genau und irgendwann steht dann aber doch mal die Kontrolle da. Das kann einfach passieren.
Markus intervenierte gerade, als ich sagte, man nimmt schon Künstlern eine Einnahmequelle, wenn man sich die Musik von denen saugt, brennt irgendwie und nicht die Platte im Laden kauft.
Wieso? Erstmal, es gibt eine ganze Menge Künstler.
Ich fahr mal mit dem Tisch ein Stück hoch. Du musst dich nicht so runter beugen.
Danke schön. Ich hätte das Mikro einfach ein bisschen höher machen können. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Künstler, die entwickeln mittlerweile ganz andere Geschäftsmodelle als den traditionellen Verkauf von irgendwelchen physischen Einheiten, die man CD nannte. Die Haupteinnahmequelle im Moment entwickelt sich so in Richtung live spielen, Konzerte machen, Merchandising spielt auch eine große Rolle. Oder halt im klassischen B2B-Licensing, also dass Labels anderen Firmen gegenüber für Werbezwecke oder sonstige Zwecke irgendwie Rechte lizensieren. Und eine ganze Menge Künstler setzen auch darauf, dass quasi der Bass, der erzeugt wird, indem ihre Fans ihre Musik weiterverteilen, Mundpropaganda erzeugen, dass das viel mehr diesen anderen Geschäftsmodellen etwas bringt.
Das ist richtig. Also viele Künstler leben mittlerweile durch Touren und live spielen ganz gut. Aber was es auf der anderen Seite ist eigentlich gar nicht Thema der Sendung, aber da können wir bei der Wunderbar darüber reden. Was es auf der anderen Seite natürlich bringt, ist, dass Künstler nicht mehr einmal im Jahr in Berlin spielen, sondern dreimal im Jahr, viermal im Jahr, dass Konzertpreise dadurch natürlich auch teurer werden. Und im Endeffekt kann ein Künstler in einem Laden oder in einem Club ja auch nur spielen, wenn der Clubbetreiber sagt oder der Veranstalter, wer auch immer. Aha, wer seid ihr? Habt ihr schon eine Platte draußen? Wenn ihr noch keine Platte haben, weil es gibt das Geld nicht dafür, dann beißt sich der Hund wieder irgendwo ins Spanz.
Genau, aber gleichzeitig kann man sich die Statistiken anschauen, wenn die Musikindustrie damit argumentiert, mit pro Original gäbe es zehn verschiedene Kopien. Da kann man einfach mal eine Geschichte reingucken. Früher, als wir Kassetten irgendwie legal hatten und mit Kassetten legal kopieren konnten, Privatkopien nutzen konnten, da gab es auch irgendwie sieben Kopien waren vollkommen von Gerichten geklärt. Also so groß ist der Unterschied zu früher auch nicht. Es gibt nur auf einmal viel mehr Künstler, die auf denselben Markt draufkommen. Früher hatten wir ja eine künstliche Begrenzung von Musikern, immer diejenigen, die im Radio gespielt wurden. Und heute gibt es einfach viel mehr Angebot. Die Nachfrage ist etwa gleich geblieben. Die Menschen haben einfach nicht viel mehr Geld dazubekommen für das riesige Angebot.
Das ist richtig, aber der ist schon wieder eine Diskussion von Zaun gebraun. Aber die Kassette ist natürlich was anderes als die CD oder die digitale Datei, die man quasi verlustfrei hin und her kopieren kann.
Das Argument höre ich auch schon seit zehn Jahren.
Es geht eben alles viel schneller. Und damit sind wir eigentlich beim Thema der heutigen Sendung. Während hier noch kleine technische Details besprochen werden. Frank, wollen wir noch eine kurze Musik spielen? Und da wir gerade bei Creative Commons waren, könnte man gleich eine aus diesem Thema raushauen. Dirk, mach dein Mikrofon auch wieder auf.
Ah, Dankeschön. Wir haben heute ganz, ganz viele Vorschläge bekommen. Ich muss ja mal wieder unsere Hörer loben, unsere Community. Die sind nämlich ganz, ganz groß dabei auf unserem Wiki auf Chaosradio. Chaosradio.ccc.de ganz viele Vorschläge zu machen und Fragen einzureichen, die sie gerne heute Abend geklärt haben möchten. Und auch Musikvorschläge zu machen. Und ich glaube, wir hören jetzt einen davon schon.
Ja, wir hören jetzt einen. Wir hören jetzt Jammin Incorporated mit Was ist härter 2.0.
Wir möchten Sie bitten, in eigenem Interesse während des nun folgenden Musikprogramms, Ihre Fenster und Türen fest verschlossen zu halten und alle anwesenden Nichtfamilienmitglieder für die Dauer der Sendung aus dem unmittelbaren Hörbereich Ihres Rufunkgerätes herauszubitten, um eine öffentliche und somit für Sie eine höhenpflichtige Aufführung auszuschließen.
Könnt ihr knicken.
Gebühren für die Künstler.
Ich bin auch selber Künstler, ich bin Lebenskünstler.
Hat ihr zwei Kinder, ein Hund, ein dickes Auto?
Ich meine, was'n los?
Geh ma!
Jammin Incorporated heißt, diese Truppe kommt aus Braunschweig. Was ist härter? Die Platte von denen heißt Mit Anlauf. Das ist Creative Commons Musik, also GEMA-freie Musik, die so im Netz steht und wo die Band ausdrücklich wünscht, dass ihr euch die Sachen auf eure Abspielgeräte wie auch immer jagt und das dann weiter verteilt, damit alle von Jammin Incorporated wissen. Ihr seid im Blue Moon im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Teil 133. Wir reden heute über Filesharing und unter der 0331 70 97 110 hat Rainer aus Berlin angerufen. Guten Abend, Rainer.
Guten Abend.
Grüße dich. Du hast schon sehr explizite Erfahrungen gemacht mit runtergeladenen Files. Was ist passiert?
Angeblich. So, bei mir ist es so, dass ich ein Anwaltsschreiben aus Augsburg gekriegt habe, dass ich am Ende letzten Jahres mit der IP-Nummer vorne 94.191 eine bestimmte Datei heruntergeladen haben soll. Daraufhin habe ich mir dann hier einen Berliner Rechtsanwalt genommen, der hat sich dann mit dem anderen in Augsburg in Verbindung gesetzt, er ist noch fernmündlich und diese Erklärung, die er unterschreiben muss, die hat er so abgeändert, dass er erstmal kein Schuldeingeständnis von mir ist und ich mich dann damit schriftlich verpflichtet habe, diese bestimmte Datei nicht mehr runterzuladen. So, das ist die eine Seite, das war Ende letzten Jahres, die haben also die Uhrzeit mit drauf und die IP-Nummer.
Das heißt, um es einfach zu übersetzen, du hast einen Brief bekommen, mit dem steht Rina aus Berlin, hat am dem und dem Tag um die und die Uhrzeit mit der und der Adresse im Internet mit deiner IP-Adresse eine Datei aus dem Netz gesaugt. Okay, soll gesaugt haben, bleiben wir mal dabei.
Ja, so, das Ververse bei mir ist, ich habe also den ADSL-Modern von einem Berliner Hersteller, ein zwei oder drei Jahre altes Typ, natürlich immer mit dem Firmenwehr-Update, das war aktuell und da hat dann Ende letzten Jahres oder im Frühjahr diesen Jahres jemand festgestellt, der in der IT-Branche arbeitet, dass das Ding von außen gehackt worden ist. So, das heißt also, kann jemand mit der gehackten Fritzbox das irgendwie ferngesteuert haben und ich habe jetzt eine Klage am Hals, wo ich wahrscheinlich diese Datei nicht gesaugt habe?
Da gibt es so einige Fälle, also der Klassiker ist ja auch mal, ich hab ein offenes WLAN gehabt, der Nachbar war es. Es ist natürlich, wenn die Sache tatsächlich vor Gericht landet, ist es immer ein bisschen schwer festzustellen für den Richter, ist es jetzt eine Schutzbehauptung oder ist es tatsächlich so gelaufen?
Bei mir ist das ADSL-Bodem mit Nubelkabel verbunden, also leider.
Ja, leider, genau, ist richtig, ja ja, leider.
Also kannst du dich nicht auf diese WLAN-Geschichte...
Genau, bei den Filesharing-Geschichten, bei der Verfolgung von Filesharing muss man immer trennen zwischen sogenannten Zivilverfahren und Zivilklagen. Das sind also die Sachen, wo die, ja, die Rechteinhaber, vertreten durch Firmen, dann auf Schadensersatz, also auf Unterlassung klagen.
Das ist genau das, was passiert ist.
Genau, das gibt die strafrechtlichen Sachen. Das ist also da, wo jetzt der Staatsanwalt eine Strafe beantragt. Das heißt also, okay, kostet jetzt irgendwie eine Geldstrafe oder so was. Das ist aber dann nichts, was an den Rechteinhaber geht, sondern an den Staat. Das heißt also, das ist dann wirklich eine klassische Strafverfolgung. Und die Strafverfolgung ist immer so, dass sie wirklich nur auf eine Person geht. Also man kann nicht sagen, hier die WG, die haben Filesharing gemacht, die stecken jetzt mal alle für eine Woche in den Knast. Das geht nicht, sondern Strafverfahren sind halt immer wirklich auf eine Person begrenzt. Bei den zivilrechtlichen Geschichten kommt dieser Begriff der sogenannten Mitstörerhaftung in Frage. Also man muss auch immer dem vorbehalten, wir sind hier alle keine Juristen. Das ist also alles Laiengeschichten, die wir erzählen. Also wir machen hier keine Rechtsberatung. Also ganz ganz wichtig, wenn immer irgendetwas geht, sofort zum Anwalt. Möglichst lasst euch richtig vernünftig beraten. Aber es ist so bei dieser sogenannten Mitstörerhaftung, da geht es also darum, zu sagen, ok, du hast jetzt quasi mitgewirkt an dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung und du hast auch dafür zu sorgen, dass es irgendwie dein Internetanschluss ist, dass es irgendwie deine Verantwortung ist. Sieh zu, dass da keiner sonst mit drauf ist. Sonst nehmen wir dich halt irgendwie hier mit in die Haftung rein. Und das ist dann offensichtlich der Fall, der da eingetreten ist, wobei es da natürlich gerade bei diesen Modems, da gibt es auch noch andere Geschichten, dass man quasi über einen zweiten Weg über den DSL-Anschluss, also quasi über einen Weg, der jetzt nicht der offizielle ist, sondern einen, der sozusagen providerintern, wie so eine Hintertür oder so was, auf diese Modems reinkommt oder beziehungsweise unter der IP-Adresse von jemand anderem was veranstalten kann. Das sind dann aber so Spezialfälle und im Zweifelsfall, naja.
Also ist das rein technisch, was Rainer gerade erzählt hat, ist es rein technisch denkbar, dass irgendjemand seinen Modem hackt und sich quasi auf seinen, meinen, wessen Internetanschluss auch immer da reinklemmt und den benutzt?
Klar ist es möglich, auf jeden Fall. Ganz ganz sicher. Das Beste ist natürlich in dem Fall, wenn man das Modem dann irgendwie sozusagen als Beweisstück hat und sagt, ok, ich hab das ausgestöpselt und hier könnt ihr euch angucken und es war tatsächlich so. Ist natürlich die Frage, ob das denn die rechte Inhaber beeindruckt, weil die sagen ja, also oftmals geht es dabei ja gar nicht um wirklich echtes Geld in Anführungszeichen, sondern es geht vor allem um die Anwaltskosten. Und die sagen, die haben die sowieso gehabt und das ist jetzt egal und kannst ja im Zweifelsfall das Geld von demjenigen wiederholen, der das Modem gehackt hat. Fertig. Dann ist die Sache für die erledigt.
Ich meine, das ist mit dem, die Rechtsanwaltsbranche, die ist ja im Laufe der letzten Zeit mit den Abmahnungen generell in der schwarzen Image, negativ image reingekommen.
Durchaus, ja.
Ich meine, ich bin Betroffener. Nee, aber ganz konkret ist jetzt, also der Provider bei mir ist ein Provider, der mit zwei Ziffern und einem Kaufmännischen unverbunden wird. Und die Frage ist, ob ihr oder einer der Hörer dazu weiß, in welchem IP-Bereich der Ende letzten Jahres und oder in diesem Jahr den IP-Adressbereich hat. Weil, das würde mich nämlich auch interessieren. Weil ich habe nämlich eine 70er-Zahl jetzt ganz vorne eine IP-Adresse und die haben auf dem Schreiben eine 84er-Adresse vorne auf dem Schreiben von dem Rechtsanwaltsbüro. So, die andere Sache ist, die auch wieder mit da rein spielt, inwieweit sind wir überwachbar, beziehungsweise was wird erfasst. Bei Arco ist es so, das glaube ich auch in einer Zeitungsstand, dass die Daten nur sieben Tage erfasst werden, die Verbindungsdaten und dann werden die gelöscht.
Aber sind sie nicht per Gesetz im Moment verpflichtet, das sechs Monate zu speichern?
Sind sie, ja. Zu speichern schon. Die Frage ist, ob die dann abgerufen werden können. Das war die Sache, was wir ganz am Anfang hatten. Aber nochmal gleich zu den IP-Adressen. Kleiner Exkurs Internet und Zugangstechnik. Es gibt sogenannte dynamische IP-Adressen. Das sind IP-Adressen, die nur für die Dauer der Einwahl vergeben werden. Kommt einfach deswegen, weil man gesagt, okay, wir haben irgendwie mehr Kunden, als wir IP-Adressen haben zur Verfügung und wir müssen die nacheinander vergeben. Vielleicht gibt es auch andere Gründe, aber das ist eigentlich der technische Hauptgrund dafür, warum nicht jeder zu Hause eine feste IP-Adresse hat, sondern man sagt, okay, die Leute wählen sich ja immer nur mit ihrem Modem mal eine Stunde am Tag ein. Die brauchen jetzt nicht eine extra IP-Adresse zu belegen, jeder, jeder Kunde. Deswegen hat man die dynamisch vergeben, weil dann kann man einfach mit weniger IP-Adressen mehr Leute abfeiern.
Das heißt, einfach andersrum erklärt, ich komme mal wieder rein. Genau.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich mich einwähle, kriege ich eine neue IP-Adresse.
Genau. Und wenn du rausgehst, kriege ich zum Beispiel ich deine.
Richtig. Genau. Deswegen ist es gerade bei diesen Beobachtungen von den Tauschbörsen ganz, ganz wichtig, dass diese Sachen wirklich auf die Sekunde, am besten sogar auf die hundertstel Sekunde protokolliert sind. Sind sie meist nicht. Dann ist noch die Frage, wie ist die Uhr geeicht? Welche Uhr geht jetzt richtig? Geht die beim Provider richtig? Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich noch nachweisen, dass die beim Provider auf die Sekunde richtig gegangen ist, weil es kann ja schon sein, dass ich mich kurz einwähle, ein paar Minuten, dann wieder raus. Jemand anders wählt sich ein und da kann im Zweifelsfall, da gab es auch schon Fälle, wo es erhebliche Komplikationen gab, wo also mal falsch eine IP-Adresse rausgegeben wurde, also die Kundendaten zu einer IP-Adresse, wo dann die Leute irgendwie Hausdurchsuchungen gehabt haben, da ging es um irgendwelche Kinder-Porno-Geschichten, das ist dann ganz, ganz fürchterlich, wenn es da jemand trifft, irgendwie unbescholtener Familienvater, verdienen, bricht plötzlich ein ganzes Leben zusammen, nur weil da irgendwie jemand sich ein paar Sekunden geirrt hat bei der IP-Adresse, wenn es um die Abfrage ging. Das kann natürlich auch immer passieren. Dass du da irgendwie einen anderen IP-Adressbereich bekommst, das ist völlig normal, weil die Provider wechseln das auch nochmal. Bei 1&1, muss ich jetzt gerade lügen, das ist glaube ich ein Telekom-Reseller, Markus Nick, genau, das heißt also letztendlich steckt da sowieso die Telekom dann irgendwie dahinter. Und von denen wissen wir, dass sie auch schon vor der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eher großzügig gespeichert haben. Muss man vorsichtig ausdrücken. Was heißt das großzügig? Mehr als andere. Es gab auch schon mal dann ein Gerichtsverfahren gegen T-Online, wo also jemand aufgrund eines Foreneintrags da ein Strafverfahren anhängig hatte, der hat aber gesagt, im Moment, wo habt ihr eigentlich die IP-Adresse oder wo habt ihr meine Daten her? Und dann kam halt raus, okay, die online speichert die halt ziemlich lange. Was dann auch vor Gericht gegangen ist und die haben gesagt, okay, ihr braucht die eigentlich gar nicht speichern, weil ihr braucht die nicht für die Abrechnung. Das ist also überhaupt nicht relevant. Es gibt keinen Grund, diese IP-Adresse zu speichern. Also müsst ihr die irgendwie auch ganz schnell wieder löschen. So und viele Provider, also es gab mal mehrere Umfragen davon auch, wo man allerdings jetzt auch schon mit zwei Jahren her oder drei Jahren, wo man mal die Provider gefragt hat, wie haltet ihr es denn eigentlich mit der Datenspeicherung? Und da ging so die Spanne von irgendwie gar nicht oder maximal 24 Stunden in unserem Zeitrahmen bis, keine Ahnung, drei Monate oder so was. Und da sind viele Provider, die sagen, warum soll man die Daten speichern? Stehen nur irgendwie jeden Tag irgendwelche komischen Polizisten hier und wollen irgendwelche Daten von uns haben, das macht uns so viel Ärger. Da haben wir überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Deswegen speichern wir die IP-Adressen gar nicht, haben wir das Problem von selbst erledigt. Fertig. Interessanter Ansatz oder du hast es wert.
Du hast gerade gesagt, dass Telekom oder die Telekom Reseller diese Daten großzügiger speichern als andere. Eine Frage, die auch im Vorfeld dieser Sendung im WIGI auftauchte, war, gibt es denn sozusagen gute und böse Provider, dass man sich das auf ihr aussuchen kann, wo man ist?
Bisher gab es das. Jetzt ist es ja durch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erstmal gesetzlich vorgeschrieben. Ja, ein gerätscher Verwaltungsverfahren. Genau, Einschränkung machen. Aber bisher gab es es schon. Es gab Unterschiede und es gab auch Gut und Böse Listen. Jetzt wird es natürlich interessant mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil man muss ja auch immer unterscheiden, welche Daten sind jetzt eigentlich die vorratsgespeicherten Daten per Gesetz und welche sind jetzt die normalen Daten, die bisher auch schon immer gespeichert worden sind. Sind es möglicherweise zwei getrennte Datenbanken bei den Providern? Werfen die das alles zusammen? Das wird sich jetzt gerade mal die Praxis zeigen, wie die Providers das halten. Und ich denke mal, da ist jetzt auch mal eine neue Umfrage fällig bei den Providern, wie es da eigentlich ausschaut.
Also vor allen Dingen muss man noch beachten, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Internetzugänge, die tritt erst am 1.1.2009 in Kraft. Das heißt, die in der Regel werden sich Provider daran halten, erst so im Dezember umzustellen.
Ja, also ja, wobei beim Zugang ist es tatsächlich schon so, dass die für den Zugang auch, da muss ich jetzt gerade in die Luft gucken, ja. Das heißt also erst dann sind sie wirklich verpflichtet, das auch so umzusetzen. Aber natürlich, sie können sagen, okay, wir machen es einfach schon.
Rainer, soweit also der kurze Ausflug in die Technik. Bei dir kann man eigentlich nicht...
Stopp, aber ihr habt die Frage noch nicht konkret beantwortet. Es war nochmal die Frage. 1&1, der Name ist ja von eurer Seite gefallen, hat jetzt im Anfang November letzten Jahres die 1&1 auch hinten, also vorne am Anfang, die 491. Ich möchte gerne mal wissen, ob mir da jemand oder vielleicht auch von den Hörern, der das hört, mir da vielleicht behilflich sein, ob das stimmt.
Na, wenn das jemand weiß, 0331 70 97 110, die Nummer vom Chaosradio auf Fritz, wir haben noch eineinhalb Stunden Zeit, vielleicht können wir dir irgendwie weiterhelfen, Rainer.
So, die andere Frage oder die Bitte ist, ob ihr nochmal den Hilferuf hinten schicken könnt mit der Sicherheit von ADSL Modems, weil der Fall ist ja bei mir ja eingetreten. Das war also das ADSL Modem eines Berliner Herstellers mit einer 50er Nummer, ob da von irgendjemand anderem auch das Modem in der letzten Zeit gehackt worden ist. Bitte dringender Hilferuf.
Okay, falls jemand helfen kann, tun wir unser Bestes, dass jeder in Kontakt kommt. Danke Rainer.
Gut, dann bedanke ich mich auch, ja.
0331-77-97-110 Chaosradio auf Fritz. Es war jetzt ein kleiner Ausflug in diese große technische Welt. Wir reden heute über Filesharing in Zeiten der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass Filesharing nicht hauptsächlich dafür benutzt wird, wie es immer verteufelt wird, nämlich zum illegalen Tauschen von Urheberrechtsgeschützten, Dateien wie Musik oder Film oder sonst was, sondern hauptsächlich dafür da ist, um große Datenmengen über große Entfernungen relativ schnell verfügbar zu machen für andere Leute. Und das wird natürlich immer wieder auch von anderer Seite missbraucht. Das sollte man da auch immer nochmal mit reinbringen. Wir hatten gerade diesen kurzen Ausflug in die Geschichte mit den IPs, mit den Floating-IPs, wie sowas funktioniert, was denn dynamische IP-Adresse eigentlich ist. Wir hatten gerade von Rainer die Geschichte, dass sein Modem möglicherweise gehackt wurde von anderen Leuten. Falls ihr ähnliche Erfahrungen habt, dann würden wir uns freuen, damit euch darüber zu reden und auch mit euren Erfahrungen oder euren Gefühlen, die ihr momentan habt, wenn ihr eure E-Donkeys oder wie sie alle heißen, BitTorrent, wo es ja tausend Möglichkeiten gibt, wenn ihr die anwerft, ob ihr euch da über die Schulter geguckt fühlt oder was euch da sonst durch den Kopf geht. 0331 77 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Max aus Tiergarten, der, oh, schönes Thema, auch RapidShare, also große Share-Hoster ansprechen wird. Aber vorher, denke ich, wenn wir ihn richtig sehen, müssen wir die Nachrichten machen, damit wir einigermaßen pünktlich bleiben. Also Max, hab Geduld, du bist der nächste.
Es kommt der Tag, da kommt sie auch zu euch.
Die Fritz Disco unterwegs. Im ganz großen, weiten, wilden Fritz-Gebiet. Kommen im Freitag ab 22 Uhr im Sound in Cottbus mit den Fritz-DJs T-Bird und Branko Jett.
Mehr Infos Fritz-D.
Die Fritz Disco unterwegs.
Es kommt der Tag, da kommt sie auch zu euch.
Fritz-Info.
Mit Matthias Zachau.
Der Lebensmittel-Discounter Lidl hat die Bespitzelungsvorwürfe zurückgewiesen. Die Geschäftsführung sagte, sie sei bestürzt über die Berichte. Eigentlich sei es darum gegangen, Diebstähler aufzuklären. Das Magazin Stern berichtet, die Beschäftigten seien mit Mini-Kameras gefilmt und ihr Verhalten sei genau protokolliert worden. So wurde unter anderem aufgeschrieben, welcher Mitarbeiter wann und wie lange auf der Toilette war. Die Gewerkschaft Verdi warf Lidl vor, gegen die Menschenwürde verstoßen zu haben. Das EU-Parlament hat China wegen des Vorgehens in Tibet scharf kritisiert. Die Abgeordneten sprachen heute auf einer Sondersitzung über einen möglichen Boykot der olympischen Spiele in Peking. Die Meinungen darüber sind geteilt. Viele Konservative und Grüne waren dafür. Gegen einen Boykot sprachen sich vor allem Sozialdemokraten aus. Auch die Deutschen kommen nach Einschätzung von Forschern extreme Wetterlagen und enorme Kosten als Folge des Klimawandels zu. Das Deutsche Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung rechnet damit, dass die Landwirtschaft unter immer mehr heißen Sommern leiden und die Ernte zurückgehen werde. Auch die Energieversorgung könne gefährdet werden, wenn Kraftwerke bei extremer Hitze kein Kühlwasser mehr haben. In den nächsten 50 Jahren könnten Kosten von rund 800 Milliarden Euro wegen des Klimawandels entstehen. Das DIW hat die Studie auf einer Tagung in Hamburg vorgelegt. Rund 700 Teilnehmer beraten dort über extreme Wetterlagen. Fußball. Zurzeit läuft die zweite Halbzeit des Länderspiels Schweiz gegen Deutschland. Es steht 3 zu 0 für die Deutschen. Ein Tor hat Miroslav Klose geschossen, zwei Mario Gomez. Und Eishockey. Die Eisbären Berlin sind ins Playoff-Halbfinale der Deutschen Eishockey-Liga eingezogen. Die Berliner gewannen gegen die Hamburg Freezers 4 zu 3 in der Verlängerung. Im Halbfinale über maximal fünf Spiele treffen die Eisbären dann ab dem 1. April auf die DEG-Metrostars aus Düsseldorf. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Potsdam Frankfurt Wittenberge und Angermünde minus 1 Grad, Cottbus und Neuropie 0 und in Berlin 1 Grad plus momentan. Die Temperaturen gehen in der Nacht runter bis auf minus 5 Grad. Schnee und Graupelschauer lassen langsam nach. Morgen wird es dann recht freundlich und meist trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 9 Grad. Auf der A12 haben wir zwischen Fürstenwalde Ost und Storkow in beiden Richtungen Stau und die A13 Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Ruhland und Ortrand steht ein kaputter LKW. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert. Hier kann es etwas länger dauern, ansonsten euch überall eine gute Fahrt.
Info Wetterverkehr mit Matthias Zachau 3 nach 11. 4 im Chaosradio geht's gleich weiter.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Das war Weird Al Jankovic im Chaosradio auf RIT 233. Zu Gast sind Jakob Kranz, meine Wenigkeit, Markus Becke Dahl von netzpolitik.org und Frank Rosengard vom CCC. Namen die Herren und wir machen jetzt weiter mit Max aus Tiergarten. Der hat nämlich angerufen, wir reden über Filesharing. Hallo Max. Bist du ein Filesharer?
Nein und ich will sagen, ich bin nicht für das illegale Downloaden und Anbieten, aber mich kotzt dann doch ein bisschen die Methode des Rechts an. Ich hab mehrere Dokus gesehen wie bei diesen Anwaltskanzleien. Ich find's ehrlich gesagt eklig, wie Leute sich selbst eine goldene Nase verdienen, denen sie andere abzocken. Also es gibt halt diese Abmahnkanzleien, welche halt für die Musikindustrie die Leute abmalen. Also ich hab's mal früher benutzt, es war wahrscheinlich als einzelne Abteilungen zu haben, die den ganzen Tag einzelne Tauschbörsen überwachen und bei den angebotenen Dateien schauen sie halt auf die IP, ich glaub des Erstverfassers oder halt der, der halt die Datei hochgestellt hat als Erster, ich weiß nicht wie das genau heißt. Und diese werden halt, die IP wurde soweit ich weiß dann ermittelt und die bekommen dann halt Abmahnungen, aber da kenn ich mich halt nicht aus mit dem Recht, wie es da heißt, ob es Abmahnungen und Verlassungserklärungen sind, wenn man es genau nennt. Jedenfalls hätte ich mal die Frage, also eine Freundin von mir, die, ihr seid noch dran?
Wir hören uns spannend zu.
Ja, ja, also die benutzt Leimbäuer und ich hab ja mal davon abgeraten, weil ich mittlerweile auch schon für sehr riskant halte. Ich habe früher Bärschei benutzt und hab dann auf Vorsitz halber die Upload-Funktion abgeschaltet, weil es empfohlen wurde, weil wer es uploadet, macht sich strafbarer, als der, der es runterlädt, so war es früher zumindest. Wie sieht es heute aus? Darf man es überhaupt noch runterladen? Und wenn, dann ohne abzuladen, also wie sieht es da aus bei Tauschbörsen?
Also die haben das Urheberrecht gerade mal wieder reformiert. Der sogenannte zweite Korb hat eine Änderung vor allen Dingen gebracht. Und zwar, dass früher war nur der Upload strafbar.
Einwandfrei oder unstrittig strafbar.
Unstrittig strafbar, aber da haben sie eigentlich nur einen Fehler gemacht bei der Formulierung des sogenannten ersten Korbes. Eigentlich meinten sie auch den Download und das haben sie jetzt nach fünf Jahren dann mal korrigiert. Also jetzt ist auch der Download strafbar.
Man kann sich nicht darauf zurückziehen zu sagen, ich hab diesen Pilz einfach am Straßenrand gefunden und hab ihn dann mitgenommen und nach Hause. Ich weiß ja nicht, wer den dahingestellt hat.
Und wie sieht es aus, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Proxy-Server im Ausland verwendet, so ist runterladen, ist man dann zerfolgbar, ist es trotzdem kontrollierbar, wenn man sich's runterlädt, zum Beispiel über einen Proxy?
Ja, in der Theorie schon. In der Praxis haben wir halt die Anwaltskanzleien, die du gerade schon genannt hast und die haben da ihre ganzen Hilfsweildaten sitzen, meistens irgendwelche armen Studenten, die dann für am mickrigen Lohn Falschherer suchen. Und die suchen sich natürlich nach bestimmten Künstlern in Tauschbörsen, zum Beispiel Scooter scheint da sehr beliebt zu sein bei den anderen.
Es gibt wirklich noch Leute, die Scooter saugen.
Ja, also anscheinend gibt es da eine große Zielgruppe und die sind halt genau auf dem Radar und da schauen die natürlich, wer hat alles gut, wer bietet gerade Scooter alles an. Und dann schauen sie natürlich auch auf die IP-Nummern, weil die interessiert halt nicht irgendjemand, der in den USA oder in Frankreich sitzt, weil das ist viel zu kompliziert, den von Deutschland aus in Abmahnung zu schicken, sondern sie schauen sich schon die IP-Bereiche an, die aus Deutschland kommen und konzentrieren sich darauf.
Wie ist es bei, wenn wir jetzt Künstler nehmen, die nicht Scooter sind oder irgendwelche Filme nehmen, wird das sozusagen permanent gescannt oder machen die Stichproben anhand von bestimmten Künstlern oder aber Firmen, die sagen, guck mal bitte bei uns ganz besonders an?
Also vielleicht sollte ich mal erklären, wie die ProMedia GmbH aufgebaut ist.
Da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hin.
Genau, die ProMedia GmbH ist eine Ausgründung der IFBI, also des Deutschen Phonoverbandes, quasi der Verband der großen Major Labels im Musikbereich in Deutschland. Da, ich glaube der ehemalige Pressesprecher oder sonst irgendwie, Herr Raschke hat sich selbstständig gemacht und hat jetzt so seine 90 Hilfsdrohnen da quasi. Genau, und sie am Mitteln auf ihrer Webseite steht in einem exklusiven Auftrag vom Phono-Weltwirtschaftsverband. So bei der IFBI muss man halt dazu sagen, da sind halt eigentlich auch nur die großen vier Majors dabei, plus ein paar kleinere Indies. Aber die große Masse der Labels ist da nicht Mitglied. Und sie suchen natürlich auch nicht nach jedem Song, der jetzt beispielsweise bei Sony Bim G aufgelistet ist, weil die haben halt nur begrenzte Ressourcen. Also von den 90 Mitarbeitern arbeiten die wahrscheinlich auch im Schichtbetrieb. Das heißt, da arbeiten auch immer nur irgendwie...
Und die Prometeer, die sind im Moment die einzigen, die sich darum kümmern.
Im Musikbereich. Es gibt für den Porno-Bereich gibt es so eine eigene Anwaltskanzlei mittlerweile für Hörspiele. Die sind gerade sehr beliebt bei der Jagd und Filme und Spiele natürlich. Genau und Spiele.
Software, Schrägstrich, Spiele.
Genau. Und die Prometeer GmbH, die hat halt da ihre Drohnen sitzen und die machen halt Filesharing. Und die schauen dann halt nach, wer bietet alles Gute an über der verschiedensten Filesharing-Systeme.
Das heißt, die loggen sich auch, ich frage immer wieder durft dazwischen, die loggen sich genauso bei LimeWire, BeerShare, wie sie alle heißen, ein und suchen auch nach Scooter und gucken dann, wer dann da quasi alles mit dransitzt an dem Honigtauch.
Und dann laden sie quasi hilfsweise eine Datei runter, drucken das Ganze aus. Ja, also sie sind halt der Meinung, sie haben den Auftrag und vertreten die Rechteinhaber und dürfen das.
Wenn du irgendwo Unsinn baust und die Polizei muss dir hinterherfahren, fahren die ja auch zu schnell in Beirut über die Ampel, die dürfen es dann auch.
Nur, dass es die Polizei ist und keine Firma.
Also das ist quasi mehr oder weniger eine Selbstjustiz-Sache, die die da machen.
Wie sieht es mit TV- und Radio-Mitschnitten aus? Also zum Beispiel Fernsehaufzeichnungen, die zum Beispiel nicht wieder veröffentlicht werden auf DVDs, gibt es da jetzt auch mittlerweile so einzelne Abteilungen?
Da kommt gleich, warte mal, da ist dann eine andere Firma für zuständig.
Warte mal, ich hol mir gleich den Martin aus Teltow ans Telefon, der hat gerade angerufen, ich glaube Martin ist genau dein Thema, oder?
Hallo, ja hier ist Martin. Genau, das ist genau meine Frage. Und zwar, hatte ich mal was gehört, dass es eine Paragraphen oder eine Einstufung jetzt gab, dass irgendwie ein Video oder ein Videorecorder, nee, Quatsch, ein Computer nicht als Videorecorder zählt. Und es ging halt darum, dass meine Frage war, dass man aus Amerika Serien, die hier noch nicht gelaufen sind, oder Folgen, die noch nicht gelaufen sind, hier getauscht wird über Freunde, ob das noch, ob das schon ein Straf war unterm Urheberrecht ist, oder erst, wenn die hier auf DVD erschienen sind, oder irgendwas in der Art. Weil ich meine Frage, ob das Tauschen von noch nicht erschienenen Fernsehserien oder Fernsehfolgen illegal ist.
Also, in den USA haben sie immer vor 30 Jahren die Copyright-Gesetze so geändert, dass jedes Release de ver quasi automatisch unter dem Copyright steht. Früher musste man das dort anmelden. Also, kannst du davon ausgehen, alles ist urheberrechtlich geschützt. Die Frage ist...
Spätestens nach deutschem Recht.
Ja, die Frage ist, entforst das jemand? Also setzt das jemand durch? Gibt es hier irgendeine Anwaltskanzlei, die irgendwelche amerikanischen US-Serien vertritt, die hier in Deutschland noch keine Rolle spielen?
Die Sache ist auch die, dass die ganzen amerikanischen Netzwerke praktisch neue Folgen, das ist jetzt ganz verbreitet offensichtlich, von ihren Fernseherinnen und Fernseher selber zum Anschauen, zum Streamen auf den eigenen Webseiten anbieten. Aber halt nur für Area Code in Amerika. Also für die Amerikaner wird angeboten als Service auf den Seiten, die neuesten Folgen sich streamend anzuschauen.
Ja, das ist auch sehr intelligent und...
Verschiebt halt die Geschäfts- und Geschäftsmodelle ein bisschen. Also vorher hattest du die Fernsehsender, die haben dann irgendwie Werbung dazwischen eingeblendet und haben darüber Geld verdient. Und jetzt machen das die Inhalteanbieter selbst. Das ist aber generell eine Tendenz, die sich auf dem Medienmarkt zeigt, dass also quasi die Fernsehstationen eigentlich fast keine Existenzberechtigung mehr haben, was sowas angeht, weil die Inhalte kann man eigentlich auch direkt beim Anbieter oder beim Hersteller kaufen. Also genauso wie man, keine Ahnung, Big Brother, muss man ja nicht irgendwie bei RTL oder Premiere oder sowas schauen, sondern kann man ja direkt bei Endemoll auf der Webseite irgendwie ein Abo abschließen und von da streamen.
Ja, bloß weil die amerikanischen Netzwerke das wohl auch umsonst anbieten zum Teil. Das habe ich so in Erfahrung gebracht.
Na, trotz alledem bleibt ja unter dem Strich bei deiner Frage stehen, ob das Ding jetzt veröffentlicht wurde oder nicht. Also damit, der im Fernsehsender gezeigt wurde oder nicht, tut gar nichts zu Sachen, sobald das Ding auf den Markt kommt. Und sei es nur in Amerika, ist es urheberrechtlich geschützt.
Also der Urheber kann selbst entscheiden, wie und welche Form sein Werk verbreitet wird.
Und das, wovon du gesprochen hast, das Durchsetzen, das Entforcen sozusagen, dass mir einer was ans Bein bindet oder man mich irgendwie verkacken will zu irgendwas, wird dann erst passieren, sobald ich irgendwie einen deutschen Drittsrecht abnehme, also der uns das versetzt hat oder irgendwas.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist höher, das möchte man jetzt nicht ausschließen, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist höher, dass das erst durchgesetzt wird in Deutschland, wenn es hier einen deutschen Rechtsvertreter gibt.
Also jemand, der das Interesse daran hat, dir da auf die Füße zu treten.
Wobei natürlich die Strafbarkeit kann trotzdem da sein oder ist trotzdem da. Und sie kann natürlich auch verfolgt werden durch eine besonders über eifrige Staatsanwaltschaft. Selbst wenn also keine zivilrechtlichen Ansprüche gemacht werden, kann es natürlich trotzdem auch strafbar sein.
Und jetzt würde ich gerne an dem Punkt machen. Martin, ich hoffe, die Frage ist in dem Moment erst mal beantwortet. Max ist noch am Telefon, du bist noch da, Max, oder? Wir kommen gleich mal zum Rapid Share, das finde ich auch ganz spannend. Aber vorher würde ich ganz kurz das Argument einwerfen. Wir haben jetzt über Filme geredet und über Fernsehserien und über Musik und solche Geschichten. Und über Spiele und Software, wo es Leute gibt, die Interesse daran haben, dass ihre Rechte gewahrt werden, wo es also die Pro Media zum Beispiel gibt, die da hinterher ist. Wie ist denn das bei anderen Dateien, die selbstverständlich auch in diesen großen Filesharing-Netzwerken verbreitet werden, die nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt sind? Du schreibst ein Programm, sagst, ich soll das bitte haben.
Also alles, was du als deutscher ins Netz stellst, ist automatisch urheberrechtlich geschützt.
Alles, was du produzierst, jedes Werk, alles, was du zur Urheberrechtlichkeit tust.
Aber es gibt natürlich zum Beispiel die sogenannte freie Software oder freie Musik, also die unter freien oder offenen Lizenzen online gestellt werden.
Freie Filme mittlerweile auch.
Wo die Lizenzen, sah explizit sagen, zum Beispiel im Softwarebereich, die GPL hinter Linux und so weiter stehend, darf jeder weiter kopieren, darf jeder weiter verwenden, weiter bearbeiten. Im Musik- und Filmbereich gibt es die Creative Commons Lizenzen und hier bieten sich halt Tauschbörsen an, weil sie halt quasi die ganze Distribution übernehmen. Also früher, zum Beispiel so ein 700 Megabyte Film, der auf so eine CD passt. Wenn du jetzt einen eigenen Film machst und den online stellst und da greifen 1000 Leute zu, dann bist du ja fast pleite, wenn du keine Flatrate hast, so bei deinem Provider. Aber wenn du das Ganze halt über BitTorrents zum Beispiel anbietest, dann wird die ganze Distribution von den Nutzern quasi mit übernommen. Und das ist eigentlich das intelligentere System und das fortgeschrittenere System. Und da werden auch traditionelle Medieninhalte hingehen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel in Norwegen die erste öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehsendung, die stellt ihre ganzen Episoden danach als BitTorrent-Download ins Netz. Es gibt jetzt in Kanada aufgrund dieses norwegischen Beispiels, da macht es kanadische öffentlich-rechtliche Sender auch bestimmte Sendungen ins Netz. Das wäre genauso wie, wenn die ARD endlich mal die Tagesschau irgendwie anbieten würde, weil sie würden Geld sparen und es würde teilweise vielleicht sogar noch schneller gehen.
Und es gibt auch mittlerweile kommerzielle Video-on-Demand-Dienste, die auch auf Peer-to-Peer-Technologien, also Tauschbörsentechnologien, zurückgreifen dabei.
Also soviel nur mal ganz kurz zum Thema Tauschbörsen. Sie sind grundsätzlich böse, böse und fuhi. Sind sie ja nicht. Wir waren jetzt gerade so weit gekommen, dass wir gesagt haben, alles was ich produziere und netzschille ist urheberrechtlich geschützt. Und wenn es irgendjemand verbreitet, muss es mit mir abgestimmt sein, ob ich dem zustimme. Ganz genau. Wenn ich das nicht tue, bewegt ihr euch in einem zivilrechtlich oder strafrechtlich, auf jeden Fall in einem, wie formuliere ich es jetzt vorsichtig? Gefährdungsbereich. Gefährdungsbereich ist ein wunderbares Wort. Danke Frank. Aber wie ist denn das jetzt bei Share-Hostern wie RapidShare oder EasyShare, oder wie sie alle heißen, also eine große Firma, die sozusagen Speicherplätze zur Verfügung stellt, damit Leute Daten da reinstellen können, die mit einem Passwort geschützt sind. Und ich komme dann da ran.
Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz an den Max war. Du sagst, du benutzt Tauschbörsen nicht mehr. Tatsächlich, weil du Angst hast oder?
Also zum einen finde ich das nicht mehr bequem. Zum anderen habe ich da bedeutend mehr Angst, als wenn ich es zum Beispiel über den Browser mache. Mit Hilfe spezieller Seiten weiß das ich. Und Tauschbörsen finde ich auch ein bisschen schade, weil ich experimentiere ein bisschen mit Linux. Und da wird natürlich vieles über Tauschbörsen servile. Aber da habe ich persönlich mittlerweile Angst, dass zum Beispiel diese Firma, die abklagt, dass die sich, wenn ich auch nur aus Versehen eine mp3 herunter lade, dass ich automatisch ein anderes Programm benutzt habe. Und dass ich sie öfter benutze, weil ich zum Beispiel mir Linux herunter lade und dass wir mir quasi irgendwas zusammendichten können. Und das machen wir leider. Und deswegen bin ich ein bisschen abgeschreckt davon. Und ich weiß nicht, ist es zum Beispiel bei Rapidshare oder bei den Hostern sichererweise im Prinzip ja auch nur FTP Server, die ein bisschen komplizierter aufgebaut sind. Wird das alles geloggt oder wie ist es mit den Downloadern?
Tja, frag mal Rapidshare, was die so alles speichern.
Also wir wissen halt nur, es gibt einen aktuellen Fall von letzter Woche. Da hatten Netlabel, was Alben und Musik unter Creative Consistenzen veröffentlicht, ihre Alben auf Rapidshare gestellt. Und auf einmal war das Album weg, gelöscht. Und sie hatten nur eine Meldung, ja aus urheberrechtlichen Gründen ist es gelöscht worden. Viele Grüße pro Media GmbH. Und sie haben dann mal bei Rapidshare nachgefragt, wie es denn das kommt. Sie wären die Urheber und so weiter. Und dann hieß es ja, oh sorry, tut uns leid, die Links zu ihrem Album, die standen direkt neben irgendwelchen NoFX Links. Und wir dachten halt, das ist alles illegal. Und da stellte sich heraus, dass die Pro Media GmbH, also quasi die Abmahnfirma da der Musikindustrie, die haben mehr oder weniger Ruhtzugriff auf Rapidshare. Und dürfen da halt quasi...
Also Ruht heißt Administratur Zugang, oder?
Die dürfen da halt eigentlich alles löschen. Es stellt sich jetzt die Frage, gibt ihnen Rapidshare auch Zugriff auf die Logfiles? Können wir jetzt nicht sagen.
Es gab auch mal eine Duct, die haben das komplette Administratorenpanel, die können die Seite nach ihren Wünschen umgestalten. Sie haben den vollen Zugriff und können einfach eine Suchmaschine benutzen und halt über die Daten durchswitchen, was ja im Prinzip nicht möglich ist.
Eigentlich kann man da nur noch von abraten, Rapidshare zu nutzen. Es gibt genug andere Konkurrenten, aber...
Und wie ist es, wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt FTP-Server im Ausland nimmt und von denen herunterlädt, ist man da verfolgt? Es gibt ja einzelne russische Seiten, zum Beispiel wo man Besieg per FTP bekommt aus dem Ausland. Ist man auch hier in Deutschland strafbar, wenn man auf einen ausländischen Server zugreift?
Also grundsätzlich ist natürlich deine IP-Adresse immer da, ganz egal wo der Server steht. Und wenn jemand dann diese IP-Adresse in die Hand bekommt, kann er dann auch wieder auf deine Identität schließen, auf deinen DSL-Anschluss.
Wie wird es denn abgefolgt, wenn man zum Beispiel hier in Deutschland ProMedia hat, die zum Beispiel beobachten auf meiner IP, was ich gerade mache, und ich lade...
Ne, ne, ne, die beobachten ja nicht deine IP-Adresse, sondern die gucken dann bei RapidShare oder in einer Tauschbörse.
Ich mein es jetzt so rum, es gibt Seiten, da kann man sich direkt Sachen runterladen von Servern.
All of MP3 oder was?
Wenn sich diese Server zum Beispiel in Russland, wenn sie virin befinden und ich sie in Deutschland runterlade, kann man mich dafür belangen. Also wie wäre es dort, oder wenn noch, noch mal ein bisschen krasser genommen, ich lad mir was von einem ausländischen Server mit einem ausländischen Proxy, den ich in Deutschland besitze, greife über einen isländischen Proxy auf eine russische Seite zu?
Also gerade bei All of MP3 ist natürlich insofern ein bisschen ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil du da ja als Nutzer den Eindruck hast, das ist eine ganz legale Seite, das ist eine ganz legale Musikkaufbörse sozusagen, oder ein ganz normaler Musikshop, wo du irgendwie Musik bekommst und dafür Geld bezahlst. Und da ist es jetzt, sag ich mal, zumindestens nicht unstrittig, ob das jetzt legal ist oder nicht, oder ob das jetzt verboten ist oder nicht.
Da gab es ja schon einige Verfahren deswegen.
Ja, natürlich, dass die deutsche Musikindustrie oder generell die Musikindustrie sagt, naja, das ist ja irgendwie offensichtlich illegal. Aber so einfach ist es natürlich nicht, gerade bei einer Seite, die jetzt sehr professionell gestaltet ist, wo man also schon durchaus mal den Eindruck bekommen kann, dass es ein legaler Dienst ist.
Aber um jetzt auf die Frage von Max zu kommen, wie ist es in diesem speziellen Fall, er sitzt in Deutschland, greift auf einen ausländischen Server mit einem ausländischen Proxy zu.
Die Frage ist, ob die Firma ProMedia auf den ausländischen Server Zugang hat.
Aber ist ProMedia wirklich die einzige Firma, die sich darum kümmert und das verfolgt?
Nein, nein, es gibt mehrere Firmen.
Also es gibt halt, ProMedia kümmert sich in Deutschland um den Musikbereich. Und es gibt in anderen Ländern natürlich andere Firmen, die sich da im Musikbereich kümmern. Also dieses konstruierte Teil mit dem Proxy-Server in Island und dem FTP-Server in Russland bedeutet einfach nur, in der Theorie kannst du irgendwie da auch irgendwie angepisst werden in der Praxis. Das ist zumindest in einer Ecke zu viel. Es sei denn, du machst jetzt irgendwie die neuesten Kinofilme, bevor sie überhaupt im Kino laufen und frisch irgendwie von der Produktion und wo es halt um riesigen wirtschaftlichen Schaden geht.
Und wie ging es darum, wenn ich zum Beispiel so eine ProSieben-Morning-Show, oder wenn ich zum Beispiel eure Chaosradio-Sendung mitschneide, sie auf Rapids herstelle, bin ich damit sofort strafbar.
Die Sendung brauchst du nicht auf Rapids herstellen.
Also da können wir jetzt auch eigentlich so nichts zu sagen, außer hast du...
Also gerade dabei, wenn es jetzt um öffentlich-rechtliche Sachen geht, können wir dir eine Diskussionsrunde mit der Verena Wiedemann, der Generalsekretärin der ARD, zu dem Thema sehr ans Herz legen. Fand statt auf dem letzten Chaos Communication Camp im letzten Sommer. Sehr empfehlenswert, weil sie da auch eine sehr konkrete, unkonkrete Ansage macht, wie das zumindestens bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen gemacht wird. Also das betrifft aber wirklich nur auf die ARD derzeit zu. Das muss ich eingeschränkt sagen. Bei ProSieben ist natürlich was anderes. Die sind privat finanziert, denen entgegen Werbeeinnahmen dadurch. Die haben dadurch wirklich auch einen, was soll ich sagen, Anführungszeichen konkreten Schaden, wie sie behaupten, oder vorgeben zu haben. Und da ist natürlich was anderes. Die sind da unter Umständen hinterher, weil die Sender ja auch oftmals nicht die rechte Inhaber sind. Das heißt also, die Sender haben zwar die Ausstrahlungsrechte, können aber jetzt nicht sagen, wir erlauben es jetzt einfach, dass die Sachen im Netz sind, sondern es könnte dann schon sein, dass die dann wieder von den Rechteinhabern die Anweisung kriegen, ok, kümmert euch darum, dass die Sachen aus dem Netz kommen.
Also im Endeffekt sind wir wieder am Anfang. Wenn der Urheber des Produktes, der Datei, der Sendung sagt, diese Sendung ist frei, stelle ich sie zur Verfügung, dann ist alles gut, solange du diese Einwilligung oder diese Erklärung nicht hast, wird es nicht funktionieren.
Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel eine Fritz-Beruhungs-Sendung mitschneiden möchte, dann müsste man bei Fritz irgendwie anfragen schriftlich, ob die denn mögen, dass man die zum Beispiel Parasite-Sharing bietet oder wie wäre es da?
Da würde dir jemand antworten, das geht nicht. Also entweder man macht es einfach oder man lässt es sein.
Schick uns mal eine Mail an chaosradioac.cdc.de, dann schicke ich hier einen Link.
Das war jetzt wieder mal ein sehr technischer Ausflug in die Welt von Proxy-Servern in Island und irgendwelchen.
Wobei die Frage taucht also auch mal wieder auf, also wie ist es eigentlich? Es gibt viele verschiedene Dienste. Also eine Variante, sei mal die extremste Variante davon, ist so ein Anonymisierungsdienst wie zum Beispiel Tor zu benutzen. Das ist an sich eine ziemlich schlechte Idee, weil gerade diese Filesharing-Sachen belasten so ein Netzwerk auch ziemlich stark.
Und die Idee von Tor ist ja eigentlich eine andere.
Richtig. Tor ist nicht dafür gedacht, um jetzt irgendwie den Musiktauschbörsen irgendwie die Sicherheit zu geben, sondern ist eigentlich da, damit irgendwie politisch verfolgte Länder mit Beschränkungen, mit dem Internet, dass die da einfach irgendwie einen freien Zugang haben. Und das muss man sich immer darüber im Klaren sein. Wenn man das Ding mit Filesharing blockiert, dann ist es eigentlich eine ziemlich scheiße Sache.
Das ist ja nicht in den USA, oder?
Das spielen doch grad die Ärzte und dann kommen wir zu Martin. Die Ärzte sagen nämlich Tu das nicht.
Bitte tu das nicht.
Chaos Radio, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio 133, Markus Becketal ist da von netzpolitik.org, wir haben Frank Rosengard vom Chaos Computer Club, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir haben noch Zeit eine Stunde lang über Filesharing zu reden. Wir haben in den vergangenen 60 Minuten schon einige Themen angerissen, Stichwort Rapid Share, Stichwort dynamische IP-Adressen, Stichwort was der Rainer ganz am Anfang auch hatte, was passiert, wenn du einen Brief bekommst von einer Anwaltskanzlerin, der drin steht. Sie haben an dem und dem Tag, zu der und der Uhrzeit, mit der und der IP-Adresse einen Film runtergeladen. Wie geht es dann weiter, Frank?
Wie geht es dann weiter? Gute Frage. Also generell ist es erst mal zum Anwalt. Es gibt Anwälte, die sind da spezialisiert drauf, die finden sich mittlerweile auch im Netz, die also diese ganze Problematik ein bisschen besser kennen und so eine Fälle vielleicht auch schon mal gehabt haben. Die können dann auch gleich am Anfang die richtigen Fragen stellen. Ja, wahrscheinlich der beste Weg ist erst mal zu schauen, war ich das wirklich oder soll ich das wirklich gewesen sein?
Hat man eine Chance zu beweisen, dass man es war oder nicht war?
Also ich kann schlecht beweisen, dass ich es nicht war. Also das ist genauso wenig, wie kann ich behaupten, dass ich was nicht habe oder so. Das ist immer schwer. Oft oder einige Fälle gibt es ja auch, wo dann auch tatsächlich mal eine Hausdurchsuchung stattgefunden hat. Und das gibt es auch immer mal wieder mal, wobei das glaube ich mittlerweile weniger geworden ist. Also zumindest dann, wenn es jetzt wirklich an Anführungszeichen kleinere Fälle geht, also wo jetzt nicht irgendwie die Filme wirklich zwei Wochen vor Kinostart irgendwie angeboten worden sind. Also bei sogenannten Release Groups oder sowas. Also wenn ich jetzt normalen Tauschbörsen nutze, da ist es, soweit ich weiß, eigentlich ziemlich wenig, dass da wirklich Hausdurchsuchungen stattfinden. Da ist tatsächlich mehr die Abmahn-Geschichte, die dann problematisch ist. Aber es kann natürlich sein, dass wirklich eine Hausdurchsuchung stattfindet und dann werden die Festplatten, den ganzen Computer, alles mitgenommen. Und dann sind natürlich die Dateien in der Regel darauf, wenn man das nicht verschlüsselt hat, wenn man seine Festplatten nicht verschlüsselt hat.
Aber die sind ja auch drauf, wenn man die Festplatte verschlüsselt hat.
Ja, aber dann sieht sie keiner mehr, wenn man es richtig gemacht hat. Also dann kann man sagen, wenn Schulden anzucken, Passwort vergessen, keine Ahnung, geht es den feuchten Keks an. Ja, Anwalt wird natürlich dann die Fragen und in der Regel wird der Anwalt dann ja, entweder die ganze Sache an Frage stellen, das heißt, ob wir doch erstmal Beweise anfordern, schauen, was liegt eigentlich vor, was hat der Provider geantwortet, könnte möglicherweise bei dem Internet Provider ein Fehler unterlaufen sein, als sie die Kundendaten zu der IP-Adresse rausgesucht haben, welche Beweise, welche Belege hat diese Firma, die die Abmahnung geschickt hat, also zum Beispiel Promedia oder auch Firma Logistep, mal noch mal einen anderen Namen reinzubringen. Was haben die eigentlich genau gemacht, um zu schauen, dass ich derjenige bin, der die Sachen anbietet und was ich da eigentlich anbiete, das heißt, haben die sich das komplett runtergeladen, haben die sich das angeschaut oder haben die nur geguckt, ob der sogenannte Hash-Wert, das ist also eine Quersumme über eine Datei, über die man eigentlich eine Datei eindeutig identifizieren kann, was in der Praxis aber auch problematisch sein kann, weil das auch mal unter bestimmten Umständen zwei unterschiedliche Dateien diesen gleichen Hash-Wert haben können. Das könnte also auch eine Möglichkeit sein. Wie gesagt, wie es ist mit der Uhrzeit, ist alles ordentlich protokolliert. Und ein guter Anwalt findet möglicherweise da schon einen Verfahrensfehler und kann da entsprechend eingreifen und sagen, also hier habt ihr gepennt und eure Kohle kriegt ihr jetzt nicht. In der Regel muss ihr aber den Anwalt trotzdem bezahlen, aber das ist dann meist deutlich weniger als diese Abmahnfirma von mir haben will.
Also nachdem, das ist ja auch ein großes Thema, der Chaosradius oder der Sendung hier auf Fritz gewesen im letzten Jahr, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, nachdem vor 14 Tagen das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung quasi gekippt wurde und drin stand, dass die Daten, die bei den Providern auflaufen, nicht an jeden sofort rausgegeben werden können, dauerte es keine zwei Stunden. Es war die Pressemeldung der Musikindustrie da, die sagten, das ist natürlich kein Freibrief, dass man jetzt wie ein wahnsinniger Musik aus dem Netz tauschen kann und Musik...
Das würde ich an deren Stelle auch erst mal behaupten...
.Musik durchs Netz schieben kann, sondern es wird natürlich trotzdem weiter verfolgt. Markus hat ja ganz schön kurz mal erklärt, wie das im Falle von ProMedia durchaus dann funktioniert. Gibt es aktuell irgendwelche Fälle, die euch bekannt sind, wo...
Also das große Problem im deutschen Recht ist auch oder im deutschen Justizsystem ist, dass selbst wenn sich hinterher nachträglich rausstellt, dass die Speicherung unzulässig war oder die Herausgabe unzulässig war, heißt es noch lange nicht, also der IP-Adress oder der Kundendaten zu der IP-Adresse heißt es noch lange nicht, dass dann das Verfahren automatisch eingestellt wird oder so. Sondern es ist ja sozusagen dann erst mal möglicherweise, habe ich dann schon irgendwas unterschrieben oder so. Das zieht sich auch alles dann recht lange hin. Und die Fristen bei diesen Abmahnungen sind auch mit Absicht sehr, sehr kurz gesetzt, dass man also gar nicht erst auf die Idee kommt, großartig irgendwelche Sachen in die Wege zu leiten oder da, sag ich mal, großartig zu erkundigen. Die sind mit Absicht schon sehr kurz. Ein Anwalt wird dann auch erst mal eine Fristverlängerung versuchen zu erreichen und dann ein bisschen genau prüfen, Beweise anfordern und sowas, das ist so der übliche Weg.
Also es soll aber auch schon genügend Fälle geben von Menschen, die halt dann einfach entweder ein Fuck You zurückgeschrieben haben oder sich gar nicht mehr gemeldet haben und die dann überhaupt nichts mehr gehört haben.
Filesharing Blue Moon 0331 7097 110 Ich haue nochmal ganz kurze Telefonnummer dazwischen. Denn nicht nur wir drei wollen hier reden, sondern wir wollen vor allen Dingen auch mit euch reden über eure Erfahrung zum Thema Filesharing im Jahre 2008. Und wollen wir schnell Martin nehmen und du deinen Satz noch zu Ende?
Ich wollte eigentlich auch nur fragen, so macht ihr es, macht ihr es nicht? Habt ihr Angst, seid ihr eingeschüchtert worden?
Macht ihr das jetzt anders?
Hast du Angst Martin, machst du das anders?
Nee, also ich nutze jetzt nicht Idonky oder sowas. Sondern ich nutze halt BitTorrent und saug da jetzt auch nicht wild drauf los, sondern gezielt, wenn ich halt was brauche, was ich mal wegen einer Bibliothek nicht finde oder... Also es gibt halt so verschiedene PDF-Dateien oder verschiedene Videos, weiß ich was, wie lern ich Gitarre, die hat man halt auch in der Bibliothek, die sind dann halt selten verfügbar, weil sich halt viele ausbauen und dann schmeißt man einfach mal einen Rechner an und taugt sich da drunter und klar, dass man damit auch Urheberrechte verletzt, aber irgendwie muss man ja auch mal da rankommen, finde ich. Und ja, also jetzt E-Donkey, also E-Nu hat ich früher mal eine Zeit lang genutzt, das wurde mir halt auch zu unsicher.
Kannst du sagen, wann das war etwa? Also was dir das Unsicherheitsgefühl gegeben hat?
Vor zwei Jahren ungefähr. Da habe ich aber eigentlich nur genutzt, um mir halt so ein paar PDF-Dateien runterzuladen. Das waren jetzt ja auch, würde ich sagen, urheberrechtlich geschützte Sachen. Und ein paar Sachen habe ich mir danach im Dach mehr noch gekauft, aber ich finde es teilweise auch einfach praktisch, wenn man sich mal Musik runterlädt, dann hat man es gleich im richtigen Format. Es ist halt ein vernünftiges MP3-Format, alles schon beschriftet. Ich kaufe mir, wenn ich mir sowas runterlade, dann halt auch noch die CD dazu. Quasi stelle ich mir gleichzeitig mit dazu, wenn mir die Musik halt gefällt. Und hab dann halt die CD und das Cover hier rumzuliegen, hab ich ja beim CD-Player, aber halt auf dem Rechner, ist dann schon alles im richtigen Format und ich hab damit nichts mehr zu tun.
Also bist du eigentlich auch ja ein fauler Geselle.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Ist einfach eine schöne praktische Sache, aber was ich mir jetzt ja nicht vorstellen kann, ist, wie man bei Torrents oder Emu oder was auch immer, wie man da unterscheiden soll oder wie man sich sicher sein kann, dass das keine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist, die ich da eingehe. Also es kann ja auch sein, dass da mal was bei ist, was völlig okay ist, was man da runterlädt.
Ja, das ist ein Argument, der das von den Verbraucherschutzverbänden in die ganze Debatte immer reingeschmissen wird. Nämlich ja, wie kann der Verbraucher sicher sein, ob jetzt irgendwie Madonna dahinter steckt oder ob etwas halt freie Musik ist oder nicht. Kann ja einfach irgendwie anders benannt sein und das ist halt ein großes Problem.
Mit welchem Gegenargument kommt denn die andere Seite, die sagt dann, wenn es da drin steht, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass es urheberrechtlich geschätzt ist.
Creative Industries, so ist ja gerade das Zauberwort, um alles zu legitimieren.
Ja, es gibt auch, da muss mich jetzt aber, Markus glaube ich mal korrigieren oder bestätigen, immer noch diese Zusatz, also wenn ein Werk aus offensichtlich rechtswidriger Quelle kommt, ist das eigentlich noch aktuell die Formulierung, gibt es die noch, oder ist die jetzt kürzlich rausgeflogen?
Ich glaube, die haben sie irgendwie umgewandelt, kann ich gleich mal sagen.
Ist denn so ein BitTorrent-Netzwerk, wie sie alle heißen, ich möchte jetzt gar keinen Namen nennen, ist das eine offensichtlich, wie du es gerade nanntest, eine offensichtlich dramatische Quelle?
Tja, gute Frage. Also gerade deswegen war es auch bei All of MC3 zum Beispiel, was wir vorhin hatten, diese russische Seite, die also sehr professionell aufgemacht ist, ist eine Sache, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht offensichtlich rechtswidrig. Und das ist auch mal das Argument gewesen. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, da muss jetzt Markus mal schnell schauen, ob diese Formulierung so noch Bestand hat. Aber das ist natürlich so bei einer Tauschbörse, also irgendwie Idanki. Also ein klassisches Beispiel ist immer, wenn jetzt ein Film irgendwie eine Woche vor Kinostart im Netz angeboten wird, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass es offensichtlich rechtswidrig ist. Aber das ist ja natürlich ein ziemlich großer Graubereich auch auf jeden Fall.
Angenommen, ich lad mir jetzt diesen Film runter. Wenn ich ihn zu Hause entpacke, stellt sich aber heraus, das ist ein Pauno von 1980. Ja gut, aber ich werde jetzt von einem Anwalt angeschrieben, dass ich mir diesen Film heruntergeladen habe. Also nicht den Porno-Film, sondern den Film, weiß ich, was das auch mal sein soll.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass das da nicht passieren wird, weil auch die Filmfirma oder die Promedia-Firma oder die Folgungsfirma, sag ich mal, wird diesen Film heruntergeladen haben und auch festgestellt haben, dass das ein Porno ist.
Achso, und dann ist gleich die nächste Frage. Es gibt ja bei E-Mail oder bei den ganzen Tower-Programm gibt es ja immer noch parallel so IP-Filter, die man sich mit herunterladen kann. Und sprich, die ganzen Anwärtskanzleien, die werden ja auch nur IP-Adressen nutzen. Bringt das denn irgendwas, wenn die IP-Adressen bekannt sind, die diese Anwärtskanzleien nutzen und dass die gebannt werden?
Ja, also sagen wir mal so, wenn du halt IP-Filter und so weiter verwendest, dann kann halt ein anderer irgendwie die Arschkarte für dich gezogen haben. Also das ist eigentlich so ein...
Das ist wieder das Schwarzfahrer-Prinzip. Mich würde es schon nicht erwischen, aber vielleicht einen Typen neben mir.
Genau, also vielleicht kann man auch mal irgendwie noch auf die Unterschiedlichkeiten von den Tauschbörsen irgendwie aufmerksam machen. Wir haben auf der einen Seite Betorrent. Betorrent bei, ja, sagen wir mal, man möchte einen Film herunterladen. Macht man das über Betorrent, ist der Film in der Regel, wenn er häufig verfügbar ist, wie ich gehört habe, so in ein bis zwei Stunden unten. Wenn man den Film jetzt über eMool herunterlädt, dann braucht er ja teilweise bis zu zwei, drei Tage. Das bedeutet halt, über eMool bietet man halt der Anwaltskanzlei irgendwie zwei bis drei Tage irgendwie so eine Breitseite an, während man bei Betorrent ja nur zwei Stunden das Risiko eingeht. Wenn man halt weiß, okay, wie viele Arbeitsdrohnen arbeiten bei denen und beobachten Filesharer und wie viele Leute machen überhaupt Filesharing, das sind verdammt viele, kann man sich das Risiko ausrechnen.
Ja gut, klar, aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass quasi wenn ich diesen IP-Filter an hab, dass sie dann trotzdem meine IP-Adresse rausher. Also ich meine jetzt nur, also angenommen diese Anwaltskanzlei hat jetzt IP-Adressen, die müssen sie ja auch irgendwie haben. Und die werden halt, die fallen halt irgendwie auf.
Ja, aber im Zweifelsfall holen die sich einfach irgendwo bei A-Core, Versatel, Telekom, wo auch immer einfach ein paar DSL-Anschlüsse und dann... Ja, so ganz blöd sind die ja auch nicht. Also die haben halt dynamische IP-Adressen einfach. Und wie gesagt, die lassen sich da einfach 10 DSL-Anschlüsse legen, kriegen jetzt mal eine neue IP-Adresse und da kannst du nix vätern.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich eher Augenwischerei.
Also es gibt in den USA, ist es tatsächlich so, da ist es offensichtlich nicht so üblich mit den dynamischen IP-Adressen oder so, oder aus irgendwelchen nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen haben die da teilweise feste Adressen. Da sind die IP-Adressbereiche auch bekannt und es gibt auch Peer Guard oder so was. Es gibt ein paar Programme, die man sich installieren kann, die diese IP-Adressbereiche dann abblocken sollen. Aber ich würde mich da jetzt nicht drauf verlassen. Also das ist eher, bringt nichts. Also die Firmen, die tatsächlich einen festen IP-Adressbereich haben, ich glaube, die kann man auch nicht ernst nehmen.
Also Martin, wir bleiben wieder dabei. Du bist eigentlich eine faule Suppe, weil du dir die Dinger aus dem Netz ziehst und du denkst, dass du einfach mit so einem kleinen Programm dich da frei machen kannst. Dem ist nicht so. Es bleibt trotzdem eine offensichtlich rechtswidrige Quelle. Und früher oder später wollen wir hoffen, dass du dir nicht die Finger dabei verbrennst, aber du bist nicht dran.
Also so auf die Propaganda irgendwie eingehen wollen wir halt nicht.
Na, wir wollen aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sagen, hurra, alles prima, super.
Und da hat man ja gar keine Wahrheit quasi. Wenn man mit manchem Programm auf dem anderen Sitzen möchte oder mal schnell an irgendwas rankommn möchte, was man sich je bestellt hat oder keine Ahnung, also ich find's...
Also man kann zum Beispiel mal fragen, wo bleiben überhaupt die legalen Angebote, um irgendwie sich Filme im Netz anzuschauen? Ich seh die noch nicht wirklich. Wo sind die legalen Angebote, um zum Beispiel jede Form von Musik, die ich gern haben möchte, in einem nicht Kopierschutzformat in Deutschland herunterzuladen in den USA? Sind da jetzt mp3 Download Stores irgendwie angekündigt? Aber in Deutschland hör ich da immer noch nix. Da werden immer noch irgendwie sehr viel Musik. Zum Glück nicht von den Indie Labels in der Regel, aber zum Beispiel so diese kommerzielle Major Musik wird in der Regel mit Digital Rights Management ausgeliefert und die kann ich bei mir gar nicht abspielen.
und Landesbibliothek, die haben ja schon relativ viele Sachen mit bei und halten sich dann und waren mal so auf dem halbwegs neuen Stand an Werken, die man sich da ausleihen kann. Dann sind die nicht immer verfügbar und dann greift man halt auch mal so aufs Netz zurück. Warum sind solche Anstalten nicht auch mal online?
Ja, aber auch dann haben die halt in der Regel nur ein Werk gekauft, was dann irgendwie dein Nachbar sich gerade ausgeliehen hat und dann darfst du halt auch nicht einfach irgendwie dir eins ausleihen.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall genug Gründe, warum man auch Musik in Tauschbörsen tauscht. Ganz klar, wenn es irgendwelche Musik gibt, wo es die Platten einfach nicht mehr zu kaufen gibt, dann steht ja auch niemanden Schaden bei. Also behaupte ich jetzt mal so, aber es gibt durchaus genug Fälle, wo man einfach aus meiner Sicht gut im Gewissen diese Tauschbörsen benutzen kann.
Jo, danke auch. Und damit kommen wir gleich zum nächsten, nämlich zu Sam, mit einer sehr berechtigten Frage. Hallo Sam, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Schieß los.
Und zwar, ich oute mich mal erstmal als Falschherrer. Ich tue das gerne und ich tue es oft. Und für mich sieht das irgendwie total absurd aus, dass irgendeine Firma hingehen kann, sich zu einem Bitterrent-Tracker verbinden kann, der Epis davon nehmt und einfach sagt, der war's. Oder sich zu mir verbindet, während ich irgendwas schere und danach irgendwann mal in einem Gerichtsprozess sagt, der war's.
Interessante Frage ist, dürfen die das überhaupt? Wer ein bisschen die Geschichte mitverfolgt hat oder das Thema mitverfolgt hat, gerade in der letzten Zeit gab es zwei Sachen, einmal in der Schweiz und in Italien auch, wo also jeweils die Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder mal in Frage gestellt haben, ob diese Firmen überhaupt berechtigt sind, sagen wir mal, personenbezogene Daten an der Stelle über die Benutzer zu erheben und zu speichern und zu verarbeiten. Die haben ja da gar nicht eingewilligt, dass deren Tauschverhalten irgendwie gespeichert wird. Und die haben also sozusagen die Legitimation oder die rechtliche Konstruktion dieser Firmen, der Abmahnfirmen, in Frage gestellt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in Deutschland auch so weit kommen wird. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich gewagte Rangehensweise. Aber zumindest in der Schweiz und Italien haben die sich jetzt erst mal lautstark dazu geäußert und sind den Firmen, die das machen, auch deutlich auf den Fuß getreten damit.
Aber das beantwortet nicht wirklich die Frage. Also es ist ja schön, dass die Leute sagen, also das, was ihr macht, geht nicht. Aber ich meine ja nicht darum, mir geht es ja nicht darum, dass es illegal ist, was die machen, sondern für mich ist diese Konstruktion, ja, du hast jetzt irgendwie ein paar Beizümer die Leitung geschickt und das ist jetzt illegal. Beziehungsweise wir sagen dem Gericht, dass du irgendwelche Beizümer geschickt hast, die angeblichen Teilen des MP3s warst.
Also das ist die moralische Frage, ob jetzt hier quasi Selbstjustiz in Ordnung ist oder nicht?
Nein, für mich ist einfach nur die Frage, warum glaubt das jemand überhaupt denen? Die können das alles selber noch konstruieren.
Moment, Moment, also wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, es geht gar nicht um eine Konstruierung, sondern sie sind Teil dieses Netzwerks, in dem du auch bist. Sie sehen deine IP-Adresse und können dann sagen, Sam aus Notendurzeldorf, Stadtteil so und so, mit der und der IP-Adresse war zu dem Zeitpunkt da.
Das ist auch die gleiche Geschichte wie beim Kaufhaus beim Ladendetektiv. Der Ladendetektiv erwischt dich beim Klauen und sagt, hier, ich hab gesehen, du hast das eingesteckt. Problematisch ist natürlich dann, wenn er die Sache dann nicht findet. Dann steht er natürlich ziemlich blöd da. Die Frage ist, ob du wirklich dann riskierst, dass du sagst, okay, wir brauchen halt sofort das SEK, was bei den Leuten zu Hause reinstürmt und die Wohnung durchsucht und irgendwie die Festplatten beschlagnimmt, wenn man es jetzt wirklich so konkret machen will, was ja dann der Schritt wäre.
Zukünftig einfach das Internet.
Ja, aber genau wie du sagst, der Laden, der hat ja irgendwie diese Süßigkeit, die ich mir in die Tasche gesteckt hab, hat er mir dann aus der Tasche gezogen.
Oder ein Zeuge der irgendwas, ganz normaler Zeuge, der irgendwas beobachtet. Kann ja auch eine Privatperson sein, muss ja jetzt kein Polizist sein. Zeuge kann ja irgendjemand sein und der sagt dann vor Gericht irgendwas aus und das Gleiche ist natürlich auch da. Ob dir das Gericht in dein entsprechend Glauben schenkt, das ist ja tatsächlich eine Frage immer. Und deswegen lohnt sich an vielen Fällen bestimmt auch, es tatsächlich auf den Prozess ankommen zu lassen, wenn er denn überhaupt niemals stattfinden wird, wenn also diese Firma überhaupt es wagt, einen ordentlichen Prozess anzutreten. Weil natürlich immer eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit besteht. Es hängt davon ab, wie fit dein Anwalt ist, den du gesucht hast. Ob er da irgendwelche Prozessfehler findet, irgendwelche formalen Fehler. Und dann sagt, ja, wie zum Beispiel in einem Fall, wo also der Geschäftsführer gesagt hat, ja, ich genau gesehen, ich war genau dabei. Und dann hat der Richter mal nachgefragt, wirklich, oder war es einer ihrer Angestellten? Ja, es war einer meiner Angestellten. Das heißt, sie haben uns nicht die Wahrheit erzählt. Schönen Dank, Sie können jetzt gehen, die Sache ist beendet. So schnell kann es denn gehen, aber das sind alles Sachen, da würde ich mich jetzt auch nicht darauf verlassen, dass es beim nächsten Mal auch wieder geht. Die Firmen lernen an der Stelle auch dazu.
Ja, aber was ich für ein Problem sehe, normalerweise ist ein Zeuge ja ein neutraler Dritter in diesem Fall, aber verschmilzt der Zeuge mit dem Ankläger. Das ist ein und dieselbe Person.
Ja, aber das ist halt so. Also wenn du irgendwie bei deinem Nachbarn hingehst und die Tür eintrittst und er war dabei und zeigt dich an, dann ist er vor Gericht auch gleichzeitig Zeuge und Ankläger.
Ja, aber der kann das mir niemals nachweisen, wenn da wirklich keine dritten Leute dabei waren oder sonst irgendwie das nachgewiesen werden kann.
Also im Zweifelsfall gucken da zwei Leute drauf. Und die werden dann vereidigt. Und dann hast du natürlich als einer, der sagt, ich war das aber gar nicht, im Zweifelsfall den schlechteren Karten. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eine Sache, wie das vor Gericht ausgeht. Und wenn der Anwalt sagt, ja, das lassen wir mal drauf ankommen, dann...
Aber die beiden Leute, die da sind, die arbeiten, die werden ja dafür bezahlt, dass die Leute will mich erwischen. Also die könnten einfach mal dumm gesagt lügen. Einfach mal sagen, ja, die IP 127 001, die war's.
Aber im Zweifelsfall wären die vereidigt. Und dann können sie nicht lügen. Wenn sie halt doch lügen, dann machen sie sich einfach strafbar. Und zwar richtig doll.
Und in dem Fall ist es glaube ich, hängt es immer sehr von den Details ab, die da alle mit drum rum zu finden sind.
Und was ist, Moment, ich habe eine zweite Frage. Und was ist, wenn ich das darauf wirklich weiter ankommen lasse und sage, ja, weißt du mir bitte nach, dass ich die Datei habe? Und kommen die hier an mit der Hausdurchsuchung, nehmen meine Server mit, meine komplette Serverfarm auf 23 Servern? Und ja, was machen die dann, wenn die sagen, ich bin der üble Terrorist, der die Daten verschlüsselt?
Ja, nee, das geht dann nur für Gerichte. Du kannst halt sagen, du klagst halt dagegen und dann brauchst du halt finanzielle Ressourcen, um quasi so ein paar Instanzen durchzustehen.
Ja, das kommt wirklich nur darauf an, die lassen einfach nur darauf ankommen, dass der Normalbürger sich gar nicht traut, so einen kostspieligen Gerichtsverfahren mitzumachen.
Kurz zusammengefasst, ja.
Und um hinten dran zu schieben, wir können im Einzelfall keine konkrete Rechtsberatung geben. Wenn du da Detailfragen hast, dich dann einfach mal mit dem Anwalt deines Vertrauens unterhalten.
Ich kann mal kurz etwas weggeben, wir kommen ja leider nicht auf IRC, aber in meinen Kommentaren hat ein Don A287 geschrieben, dass die IP-Filter im Bereich eMool, über die wir eben gesprochen haben, nicht dazu dienen, den User abzusichern, sondern die sollen nur bekannt gewordene mutmaßliche Verbreiter von fehlerhaften Paketen und Shanks aussperren. Also das ist halt eher so, um überflüssige Informationen wegzumachen. Und Tim meinte gerade über Twitter, dass vier Fragen zur Verfolgbarkeit von BitTorrent, das Chaosradio Express Nummer 57, sehr gut leistet.
Richtig, guter Hinweis, genau, Chaosradio Express können wir auch nochmal wieder drauf verweisen. Da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Hintergrundinformationen, das sind vielleicht Sachen, die viele von euch ein bisschen vermissen in der letzten Zeit, nämlich die technischen Detailfragen, die dann teilweise auch sehr nerdig sind. Aber alles, was ihr sozusagen noch mehr darüber hinaus wissen wollt, also alles, was euch, sag ich mal, an technischen Details hier zu kurz kommt, gibt es auf jeden Fall auch im Chaosradio Express nachzuhören. Das ist ein Podcast, der unregelmäßig regelmäßig rauskommt. Und da gibt es auch was zum Thema BitTorrent.
Alles unter chaosradio.de.
Genau, wo man also auch diese Sendung, die hier stattfindet, sich als Podcast in Ruhe noch mal mitnehmen kann und sich in Ruhe zu Gemüte führen kann. Guten Abend nach Thorsten, zu Thorsten. Hallo Thorsten. Wir kommen jetzt mal wieder zu Musik, nachdem wir uns jetzt sehr viel in technischen Details von Serverfarben beschäftigt haben.
Ich meine, die Debatte, die bisher geführt wurde, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen müßig auf Dauer. Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Debatte der Musikindustrie oder generell der Content-Industrie über die Verteidigung ihrer eigenen Geschäftsmodelle. Und ich glaube, das gehört letztendlich der Vergangenheit an. Man muss ja auch mal fragen, wie kann man eigentlich Geld verdienen als Künstler im Internet?
Du kommst jetzt garantiert mit zwei aktuellen Beispielen.
Das eine aktuelle Beispiel ist halt die Ben 9 Schnells, die vor kurzem ihr neustes Werk im Internet-Distribut verteilt hat. Man konnte sich verschiedene Bezahlmodelle sozusagen aussuchen. Das fing an bei 5 Dollar, den Download, für den Download. Und es ging hoch bis zu einem exklusiven Vinyl- und CD-Album für 300 Dollar mit persönlicher Signatur von Trent Reznor.
Das ist im Endeffekt dieselbe Geschichte, die Radiohead auch gemacht hat.
Genau. Und ich weiß jetzt die konkreten Zahlen nicht ganz genau, aber ich meine innerhalb der ersten Woche waren sie schon über eine Million Dollar, die sie damit verdient haben, was natürlich auch nicht schlecht ist. Also das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Ausbeute. Und ich glaube, da liegt einfach die Zukunft. Und die Musikindustrie hat es einfach nicht verstanden, das Internet als Verteil, als Verteilmedium zu nutzen. Und das wird sie, glaube ich, auch nicht verstehen. Denn das Problem bei diesem aktuellen, nein, ein schnelles Beispiel ist einfach, dass die Musikindustrie da schlicht und ergreifend nicht vorkommt. Denn die Band hat es selber in die Hand genommen, ihr Album zu verteilen.
Genau, das ist ein Deal zwischen Trent Reisner und seinem Fan.
Genau. Und im Übrigen war es dann auch so, ich glaube, man musste es irgendwie kaufen, um da erst mal ranzukommen. Man konnte aber und kann es nach wie vor weiter verteilen. Also ich kann jetzt sozusagen das Album, was ich gekauft habe, bei BitTorrent oder sonst wo reinstellen, weil eben Nine Inch Nails auf ihr klassisches Recht das selber zu verteilen verzichten haben und gesagt haben, okay, die User, die kaufen es und können es dann auch weitergeben. Und zwar nicht nur an die berühmten fünf oder sieben Freunde nach deutscher Rechtsprechung, sozusagen die Privatpuppi, sondern an wen auch immer.
An der Stelle zwei Einwände ganz kurz. Zum einen gab es gerade eine Diskussion mit auch Bands aus Deutschland zu dieser Geschichte, die wir bei Fritz auch geführt haben, unter anderem mit den Beat Stakes, die sagten, wenn man Radiohead ist oder Nine Inch Nails und mehrere Millionen Platten schon verkauft hat, dann kann man sich so ein Geschäftsmodell auf jeden Fall erlauben. Aber wenn man eine kleinere Band ist, die nicht sozusagen das finanzielle Polster hat, auszuprobieren, was passiert und im Zweifelsfall nichts damit zu verdienen, dann ist dieses Modell natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Aber die Idee dahinter an sich ist auf jeden Fall cool. Markus?
Genau Radiohead und Nine Inch Nails haben in diesem Fall eigentlich auch nur Geschäftsmodelle aus dem Internet kopiert. Sie hatten natürlich den Vorteil, sie haben schon eine riesige Community drum herum. Aber eigentlich ist das durch Netlabels, die so vorgehensweise dieses Geschäftsmodell groß geworden und bekannt geworden. Und es gibt beispielsweise magnatune.com. Das ist ein britisches Netlabel, die genauso wie Nine Inch Nails Musik unter einer Creative Commons Lizenz veröffentlicht haben. Das heißt, bestimmte Nutzungsfreiheiten werden von den Urhebern gewährt. In diesem Fall halt die Weitergabe zu nicht kommerziellen Zwecken. Also man darf es weiter kopieren, man darf es auch unter bestimmten Bedingungen remixen. Und MagnaTune verdient einerseits dadurch, dass sie halt über 50 Künstler haben und eine ganze Menge Musik. Und man kann halt diese Musik auf CD erwerben, wenn man möchte. Man kann sie aber auch zu einem selbst definierten Preis downloaden. Diese CD wiederum bietet auch nur einen Mehrwert an. Also einen Mehrwert quasi, indem man halt sagt, ich möchte was haptisches haben. Dafür zahle ich halt gern 10 Euro und schickt sie mir. Gleichzeitig verdient MagnaTune am meisten Geld im sogenannten B2B Bereich. Also sie nehmen halt dem Wissen des zu Konsumer Bereich. Also ich verkaufe mehr Werte oder ihr zahlt mir das was ihr für notwendig haltet. Lizenzieren sie sehr viel für Werbung, für Dokumentarfilme und so weiter. Und kriegen da halt tatsächlich am meisten Geld. Und kriegen ansonsten sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit über dieses andere Modell.
Tausend geschlagte vor, dass wir, wir müssen ja gleich die Nachricht machen, dass wir bis zu den Nachrichten noch ein Stückchen aus diesem Radiohead Album hören. Und jeder der sich mit dem Gedanken schwanger trägt, Musik zu machen und davon leben zu wollen, kann sich ja schon mal überlegen, wie er die erste Million Platten absetzt, damit er bei der zweiten Platte sich so ein Geschäftsmodell auch erlauben kann.
Ja okay, vielleicht noch ein ganz kurzer Hinweis zum Thema Net Labels. Gibt es auch ein Chaosradio Express. Da kann man jetzt auch noch mal alles nachhören, welche Geschäftsmodelle dahinter stecken, wie sich es in der Praxis so bewährt. Auch sehr empfehlenswert.
Hallo, ich bin Christian Ullmann und neben mir steht die liebe Kathrin Thüring, Tagchen. Genau, zusammen haben wir vor kurzem eine Sendung moderiert, die hieß, die hieß, woher sollen wir das wissen? Ah ja, genau, jetzt geht das endlich weiter. Quasi, woher sollen wir das wissen? Oder woher sollen wir das wissen? Reloaded? Die Rückkehr der Besserwisser? Oder woher sollen wir das wissen? Jetzt erst Recht? Blah, Blah, jedenfalls brauchen wir dafür eure Hilfe.
Denn dieses Mal stellt ihr die Fragen und helft uns bei der Auflösung.
Und das alles im Blue Moon.
Fritz präsentiert, woher sollen wir das wissen? Der Blue Moon mit Christian Ullmann und Kathrin Thüring.
Habt ihr unfassbar spannende, oft gestellte, doch nie geklärte, vor allem ganz schön verzwickte Fragen?
Dann schickt sie per Mail mit Name und Telefonnummer an wissen-at-fritz.de und seid live dabei, wenn es wieder heißt, woher sollen wir das wissen? Ab Donnerstag, 3.
April.
Und dann achtmal am Donnerstag ab 22 Uhr.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Und?
Wird das lustig?
Fripp Info Nachricht Mit Matthias Zachau Auch die Deutschen kommen nach Einschätzung von Forschern extreme Wetterlagen und enorme Kosten als Folge des Klimawandels zu. Das Deutsche Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung rechnet damit, dass die Landwirtschaft unter immer mehr heißen Sommern leiden und die Ernte zurückgehen werde. Auch die Energieversorgung könnte gefährdet werden, wenn Kraftwerke bei extremer Hitze kein Kühlwasser mehr haben. In den nächsten 50 Jahren könnten Kosten von rund 800 Milliarden Euro wegen des Klimawandels entstehen. Das DIW hat die Studie auf einer Tagung in Hamburg vorgelegt. Rund 700 Teilnehmer beraten dort über extreme Wetterlagen. US-Präsident Bush hat mit Chinas Staatschef Hu Jintao telefoniert und sich besorgt über das Vorgehen Pekinx in Tibet geäußert. Bush appellierte an Hu Gespräche mit dem geistlichen Oberhaupt der Tibetern, dem Dalai Lama aufzunehmen und Diplomaten in die Unruheregion zu lassen. Auch das Europäische Parlament kritisierte das Vorgehen der chinesischen Behörden, allerdings waren sich die Parlamentarier nicht einig über einen möglichen Boykott der Olympischen Spiele in Peking. Vor allem Konservative und Grüne waren dafür, Sozialdemokraten meist dagegen. SPD und Grüne in Hessen wollen die Studiengebühren wieder abschaffen. Beide Parteien legten in Wiesbaden ein gemeinsames Konzept vor. Neben den allgemeinen Studiengebühren von 500 Euro pro Semester sollen auch die Gebühren für Langzeitstudenten wegfallen. Die Einnahmen, die den Hochschulen wegfallen, sollen sie vom Land bekommen. Die Abschaffung der Studiengebühren war Bestandteil der Wahlprogramme von SPD, Grünen und Linkspartei, die zusammen eine Mehrheit im neuen Landtag haben. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat das EM-Testspiel gegen die Schweiz mit 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Tore schossen Klose, zweimal Gomez und Podolski. Die Eisbären Berlin sind ins Playoff-Halbfinale der deutschen Liga eingezogen. Die Berliner gewannen gegen die Hamburg Freezers 4 zu 3 in der Verlängerung. Im Halbfinale über maximal fünf Spiele treffen die Eisbären ab dem 1. April auf die DEG Metro Stars aus Düsseldorf. Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Potsdam-Frankfurt, Wittenberge und Angermünde minus 1 Grad, Cottbus und Neuropie 0 und auch in Berlin 0 Grad. Die Temperaturen gehen in der Nacht runter bis auf minus 5 Grad. Schnee und Graubeschauer lassen langsam nach. Morgen wird es dann ein recht freundlicher Tag. Es bleibt meist trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 9 Grad. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Potsdam. Zwischen Rassplatz Siedener-Elzbruch und Dreierknutetal haben wir Stau. A12 Richtung Berlin, auch zwischen Fürstenwalde West und Storkow staut zurzeit. A13 Richtung Dresden, zwischen Ruland und Ortrand gibt es immer noch Behinderungen wegen eines kaputten LKWs, der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert. Und A24 von Berlin kommend, zwischen Dreierquitsch, Stockdosse und Sukow fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier bitte Vorsicht, ansonsten euch eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann fritz rund um Sprenne.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Oh, leere Taschen, die Trinken waschen, die ganzen Getränke und die morschen Gelenke, die geprabbelten Wörter, der gedunstene Körper, meine Ansichten und die lieben Geschichten. Und wenn sie mich sehen, werden sie mich verstehen. Die schleckten Verstecke, die herren Gedecke, die verlorenen Wochenlenden, der Trieb meiner Lenden, die schlechten Gerüche, die tierlichen Sprüche, die falschen Wahlen und die gerechten Fahnen. Und wenn sie mich sehen, werden sie mich verstehen. Kein Lippenstift auf meinem Kragen, feste Spuren auf meinen Schuhen. Schuhen. Nur die verlorenen Freunde, die gestorbene Träume, die Normalitäten, abgebrochene Diäten, selbstverschuldete Ängste und geduldete Zwänge, die leeren Taschen und die tristen Maschen. Der Lippen stirbt auf meinem Kragen. Fisselspuren auf meinem Schuh. Sehen, werden sie mit verstehen. Mein Gott, ich bereue alles.
Hallo Mona Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio Teil 133. Das war ein Superpunk mit Ja, ich bereue alles. Im Chaos Radio reden wir heute über Filesharing. Markus Becke da, alles da, von netzpolitik.org. Frank Rosengrad vom Chaos Computer Club ist hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir würden uns über eure Anrufe freuen unter der 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über Filesharing, eure Erfahrung beim Filesharing im Jahre 2008, auch nach der Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung. Hat sich euer Verhalten beim Filesharing oder beim Surfen verändert? Habt ihr Angst, wenn ihr euch in diesen Tauschbörsen bewegt? Nutzt ihr den nicht mehr? Macht ihr irgendwelche anderen Sachen? Wir haben uns schon ein bisschen genähert der dynamischen IP-Adresse. Wir haben erfahren, stellenweise wie ProMedia, die ProMedia GmbH funktioniert, die also Filesharer jagt. Und wir haben auch schon erfahren, dass sowohl Up als auch Download, also das Anbieten und das Saugen von urheberrechtlich geschützten Dateien, rechtswidrig ist und dass da nicht das Unwissen schützt zu sagen, ich wusste ja gar nicht, was alles dabei ist. Nächste am Telefon ist Felix. Hallo Felix. Na, Wendt.
Deine Frage.
Ja, also ich hab mir vorhin mal überlegt, also ein Freund von mir, der geht völlig sorglos mit Filesharing um, er hat sein Rechner Tag und Nacht laufen und ist sich da ständig irgendwas am ziehen. Aber da bin ich schon immer darauf am warten, dass der mal irgendwann mal Post bekommt. Bei mir ist es so, dass ich also tatsächlich seit ner ganzen Zeit jetzt darauf verzichte, irgendwie Musik aus dem Internet zu laden. Und also die Sachen, die ich lade irgendwie über BitTorrent, das sind eigentlich mal Sachen, die jetzt so gar nicht lizenziert sind in Deutschland. Also die man auch sonst nur woher bekommt, die vielleicht irgendwo im fernen Asien lizenziert sind und vielleicht irgendwann in 20 Jahren hier auf den deutschen Markt kommen. Und insofern fühl ich mich da eigentlich mal relativ sicher, weil ich denke also, dass da jetzt niemand, weil es da keinen deutschen Markt gibt, da jetzt niemand auf die Idee kommt, das zu verfolgen. Aber meine Frage ist eigentlich eine ganz andere. Und zwar, mich würde mal interessieren, ob jetzt eigentlich überhaupt der Versuch, das herunterzuladen, strafbar ist. Also man hört ja immer so diesen Spruch, der Versuch ist strafbar, das ist die Frage.
Also du meinst jetzt, um das mal zusammenzufassen, wenn du also ein BitTorrent-Netzwerk hast, wo man also von verschiedenen Leuten immer so einzelne Schnipselen bekommt, ob der einzelne Schnipsel schon ausreicht, zu sagen, das ist offensichtlich recht schwierig.
Also gerade bei Torrent ist es ja so, dass ich mir in der Regel erstmal von so einer Webseite oder von einem Freund ein sogenanntes Torrent-File bekomme, was sozusagen wie so ein Index ist oder ein Hinweis irgendwo drauf hin. Und da ist es glaube ich ziemlich unstrittig, dass das Runterladen von diesem Torrent-File erstmal nichts Relevantes ist, weil das ist ja kein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material.
Das ist ja nur ein Link, ja.
Das ist ein Link sozusagen. Und ob das Anbieten davon jetzt möglicherweise, also dann muss man dann auch wieder deutlich trennen zwischen tatsächlich der Strafbarkeit und der zivilrechtlichen Ansprüchen, Unterlassungsansprüchen. Da ist dann auch oftmals der Gesamtschau interessant. Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein Richter raufschaut, ist es jetzt zivilrechtlich, gibt es einen Unterlassungsanspruch, dann schaut er, wie sieht das Angebot aus? Also ist das jetzt sozusagen mal so eine einmalige Sache? Oder ist das jetzt da eine Webseite, die darauf ausgerichtet ist, Urheberrechtsverletzungen im großen Stil zu ermöglichen?
Aber um auf die Frage von Felix einzugehen, ist also der Schnipsel eines Torrent-Files. Ist das schon ein Problem?
Jetzt könntest du es ja nicht angehen, aber ich weiß es.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so, dass auch 10 Sekunden von einem Musikstück auch urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Also ist jetzt nicht nur so, dass ein Musikstück erst dann urheberrechtlich geschützt ist, wenn es komplett auf meiner Festplatte ist, sondern auch wenn ich nur die ersten 10 Sekunden habe oder irgendwo in der Mitte 30 Sekunden mal hab, einen Block, dann ist es natürlich auch urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material.
Ja, ich hab mich nicht öfter mal überlegt. Das war die Frage, weswegen ich eigentlich angerufen hatte, weil ich hatte bis jetzt immer nur gehört, dass diese Anwaltskanzleien, die Abmahnkanzleien da irgendwie immer gucken, wer die Sachen anbietet. Und hatte bis jetzt noch nie davon gehört, dass tatsächlich die Leute verfolgt werden, die jetzt irgendwie downloaden. Also da haben wir drüber geredet, genau. Und jetzt hatte ich mich überlegt, wie kann man das überhaupt technisch machen? Weil das sind ja alles Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke. Wie kann man das jetzt rauskriegen, ob jetzt irgendjemand von irgendjemandem an was downloadet? Da habe ich mich gefreut, wie das technisch gehen kann.
Also da gibt es einen juristischen Fachbegriff des Anscheinbeweises dafür. Das heißt, wenn der Richter hinreichend davon überzeugt ist, dass es so war, dann würde er das auch erst mal so hinnehmen. Das heißt, wenn die glaubhaft machen, wir haben jetzt hier die Tauschbörse und wir haben jetzt irgendwie, sage ich mal, 20 Prozent, also irgendwie zwei von zehn Blöcken oder so was, haben wir jetzt von ihm runtergeladen und zum Schluss kam eben dieses Musikstück raus, dann können wir wohl davon ausgehen, dass der auch das Musikstück da angeboten hat.
Ja, aber wie ist das, wenn ich es downloade? Wie kriegen die das raus? Wenn ich jetzt hier von meinem Rechner aus, jetzt von einem ganz anderen Rechner, von einem Freund sage ich mal, da das Stück unterlade.
Also wenn du eine Tauschbör oder ein System hast, was tatsächlich hundertprozentig nur downloadet und nicht uploadet, also auf keinen Fall irgendwelche Sachen für andere zur Verfügung stellt, dann wird es natürlich schwer, weil in dem Fall, wo sie das dann anbieten, also angenommen, der Rechteinhaber würde das selbst anbieten, dann würde es ja auch zum Download frei geben quasi, also dann würde er auch die Rechte verlieren oder verliert in der Praxis auch die Rechte.
Nee, das sind sogenannte Honeypots.
Das ist richtig, aber da gibt es ja die Geschichten mit der GVU, die möglicherweise auch selbst Server betrieben haben sollte. Und da gibt es zumindest unter Juristen verbreitet die Ansicht, dass in dem Moment, wo also dann der Rechteinhaber selbst an der Verbreitung, an der vermeintlich illegalen Verbreitung beteiligt ist, verliert er auch die Rechte.
Ja, aber ist er eigentlich auch, also wenn ich noch an früher denke, wie Emul da aussah, man lädt sich eine Datei runter und sieht dann, bei welchen Leuten man in der Warteschlange drin steht, quasi. Und man befindet sich da eigentlich auch schon, um an diese Datenwörbler ranzukommen in einem solchen Prozess.
Das ist richtig, aber das ist tatsächlich die Frage, ist es dann schon so?
Und da können wir jetzt aber juristisch nicht...
Juristisch können wir dazu nichts sagen. Da geht es ja darum, den Richter zu überzeugen. Es kann jetzt sein, der Richter sagt, ja, war halt der Versuch, aber der hat ja noch nichts auf der Festplatte gehabt. Machen wir jetzt nichts weiter. Ich kann sagen, ja klar, das ist ja eine Tauschbörse. Also das engt auch mal vom Richter ab.
Also auch hier können wir sagen, es gibt keine allgemein gültige Formel dafür. Im Zweifelsfall, wenn du da Bauchschmerzen hast, Felix, unterhalte dich mit dem Rechtsanwalt deines Vertrauens.
Ja, Fioris ist eigentlich der Streitbettbett, das ist bei so einer Sache mittlerweile, bei einem Song.
Das ist total unterschiedlich. Wir haben da zum Beispiel das Landgericht Köln, die berechnen 10.000 Euro. Also wenn man drei Alben irgendwie bereitstellt, dann hat man Streitwert von einer halben Million Euro Schaden.
Also ganz kurz, der Streitwert ist sozusagen der strittige Wert, um den es geht. Und der ist deswegen sehr besonders interessant, weil sich die Vergütung des Rechtsanwaltes oder der der Abmahnkanzlei auch danach richtet.
Genau, aber Landgericht Köln ist bisher Spitzenreiter in Deutschland. Da scheint die Richterin in so einem Gerichtsurteil aus dem letzten Jahr irgendwie sehr musikoindustriefreundlich gewesen zu sein. Dann gibt es halt Hamburg, die haben gleich einen Streitwertkatalog entwickelt. Da wird das alles gestaffelt, also 6000 Euro für den ersten Song, 3000 Euro für den zweiten bis fünften Song, so 1500 Euro für den sechsten bis zehnten Song. Und ab dann wird es immer billiger. Also insgesamt dieser Streitwertkatalog folgt aus dem Wettbewerbsrecht. Und insgesamt ist das aber sehr problematisch, weil mit so einem hohen Streitwert kommt man auf generalpräventive Erwägungen durch die Gerichte. Und das ist ein großes Problem. Weil so ein juristischer Streit zwischen juristischen Problemen darf ja nicht so die allgemeinen Probleme der Musikindustrie betreffen. Und das ist halt relativ unrealistisch dadurch.
Das heißt jetzt was?
Ja, also irgendwie im Wettbewerbsrecht ist das eigentlich so, dass man das halt juristisch irgendwie trennen müsste.
Um da kurz mal einzugrenzen. Weil ich glaube, du wirst jetzt sehr nerdy, sehr technisch und sehr juristisch. Felix, ich danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Und wir gehen mal nach Leipzig. Da kommt nämlich Hans her. Der hat angerufen und es geht jetzt. Wir haben viel über Filesharing geredet, die ganzen Probleme. Hans sagt, Filesharing ist von vorgestern. Es gibt Alternativen. Name, Hans.
Das, denke ich, kann man einfach so weiter da beibehalten. Die Plattform, wo man sich die Musik runterholt, ist die interessante, die ich hier mal kurz vorstellen möchte. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon gesagt wurde. Das jamendo.com, das ist so ein großes französisches Musikportal, die jetzt mittlerweile über 7.900 Alben von Musikern anbieten, die per P2P unterzuladen sind. Alles mit Creative Commons Lizenz und ja, kostenfrei und sicher, dass man dort nicht verfolgt wird. Von übereifrigen Anwälten. Amüsant finde ich übrigens auch die Diskussionskultur, wie sie jetzt so ein bisschen angelegt wurde. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die 90er, wo Computerzeitschriften angeschrieben wurden, weil Benutzer ihr Code-Rad für ihr Monkey Island Spiel verloren haben. Es können dann immer solche Ausflüchte, ja ich habe das Spiel ja original gekauft, aber mein Code ist weg. Ich kann es jetzt leider nicht mehr benutzen. Genauso wird hier argumentiert. Ich brauche jetzt das Lied und nur das eine Lied. Und ich weiß, dass ich jetzt hier oben Verstoß begehe, aber die Content-Mafia ist ja so schlimm. Die haben es nicht anders verdient. Ich finde das ist ein bisschen Bigot an der Stelle. Interessant natürlich euer Einwurf. Es handelt sich nur erstmal um Transportprotokoll. Das P2P. Aber wenn es dann eben gesagt wird, es braucht wird, um sich diesen geschützten Content runterzuziehen, dann wird das Ganze natürlich ad absurdum geführt. Und wenn sie jetzt mittlerweile schon über eine Stunde darum die Sendung dreht, wie man am besten argumentieren kann, bei einem Anwalt oder vor dem Gericht, wie man irgendeinen Schaden abwenden kann, wenn es zu spät ist, dann wird das Ganze wieder umgekehrt.
Weil urheberrechtlich geschützte Dateien bleiben, urheberrechtlich geschützte Dateien, egal wie man sie da rankommen will. Deswegen merken wir uns jamendo.com. Danke, Hans.
Wo wir noch so zehn Minuten haben, sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch auf eine Sache ganz dringend eingehen. Und zwar wird der Bundestag am 11. April die EU-Richtlinie zur Durchsetzung geistigen Eigentums beschließen. Die diskutieren sie seit ganzen fünf Jahren. Und dort ist unternahm ein sehr strittiger Punkt das sogenannte Auskunftsrecht. Und zwar im Moment läuft das ja alles so mit den Filesharingen. Also die ProMedia GmbH oder andere, die sitzen da, kriegen eine IP-Nummer, stellen eine Strafeanzeige bei der Staatsanwaltschaft. Und die, wenn sie jetzt nicht in Bruppertal oder Offenbach sitzen, kommen dem auch nach und liefern dann die Daten weiter, wenn die Strafeanzeige irgendwie fallen gelassen wird, zum zivilrechtlichen Verfahren. Das sogenannte Auskunftsrecht, damit möchten die Rechteinhaber sofort das Recht haben, quasi beim Provider anzurufen und zu sagen, wir haben hier die IP-Nummer XYZ und geben sie uns mal die Daten raus, ohne überhaupt den rechtsstaatlichen Umweg über die Staatsanwaltschaften zu machen. Und wenn die Union sich letztendlich durchsetzt, und das sieht halt so aus, dass die SPD da mitgehen wird, dann werden wir demnächst halt so ein Auskunftsrecht haben, spätestens über den Bundesrat. Und hier habt ihr noch die Möglichkeit, eure Bundestagsabgeordneten zu kontaktieren. Ich glaube, FDP, SPD und CDU sind für so ein Auskunftsrecht. Bei FDP bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, weil da auch Datenschutzbelange dabei sind, aber die sind sehr Urheberrecht verfolgungsfreundlich.
Kann man da vielleicht mal ein konkreteres Beispiel an für dieses Auskunftsrecht konstruieren? Was würde im Detail passieren?
Die ProMedia GmbH sitzt dann da und hat eine IP-Nummer. Sie sieht halt, du bist auf der anderen Seite mit Scooter Filesharing. Dann rufen sie sofort den Provider an, weil sie erkennen können, eine IP-Nummer gehört halt Telekom. Hier tauscht jemand einen Scooter, geben sie uns mal sofort die IP-Nummer. Die IP-Nummer sind die Kundendaten. Dann schicken sie dem Kunden sofort eine Abmahnung. Und quasi die Provider werden zu Hilfs-Scheriffs gemacht. Und ja, der ganze rechtsstaatliche Vorgang, das halt noch eine Staatsanwaltschaft sagen könnte, ne, das akzeptieren wir jetzt nicht. Das ist ein Bagatellfall oder sonst irgendwie, wird halt umgangen.
Vielleicht ein kleines Detail dazu. Also auch die Musikindustrie hat sich schon überlegt, wie man diese ganzen Abmahngeschichten und Benachrichtigungen von Internetprovidern und sowas auch effizienter gestalten kann, automatisieren. Das heißt, sie haben mittlerweile auch ein eigenes Dateiformat entwickelt, ein eigenes Kommunikationssystem, wie sich die Industrie, die Provider, sich über Rechtsverletzungen der Kunden informieren können und auch Auskunft abfragen können und sowas. Da haben die sich also schon Gedanken gemacht, wie man das technisch alles sehr automatisch machen kann. Und ja, wird sich dann zeigen, ob das Ganze dann auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht Bestand hat. Ich persönlich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, wenn jetzt sogar schon die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die Auskunftsrechte beschränkt haben, weil das ist ja nochmal eine ganz, ganz gröbere Form. Also das ist eigentlich so, es ist so völlig absurd, sowas zu fordern und diesen rechtsstaatlichen Weg zu umgehen, dass ich da meine Bedenken habe, dass das auch wirklich Bestand hat. Aber es wird natürlich jetzt erstmal verabschiedet werden und dann muss erstmal wieder jemand klagen. Und das ist eine ganz, eine ziemlich lästige Sache.
Und man muss halt noch zwei Sachen mehr beachten. Einerseits auf EU-Ebene ist schon der zweite Teil dieser Richtlinie zur Durchsetzung geistigen Eigentums beschlossen worden. Da geht es nicht um zivilrechtliche Maßnahmen. Wir halten so ein Auskunftsrecht. Da haben sie sofort irgendwie Kriminalisierung von Tauschbörsennutzern beschlossen. Das wird auch irgendwann auf Bundesebene kommen. Und irgendwann, wenn wir dann eine große Koalition haben, sieht es dann auch ganz schlecht damit aus. Das ist die eine Sache. Und was du meinst, diese automatisierten Verfahren in Frankreich. Und haben wir schon gesetzt, in England auch, glaube ich, jetzt. Und in Deutschland hat die Musikindustrie die Diskussion auch schon gestartet, dass man halt für Tauschbörsennutzung oder für illegales Filesharing erst mal eine Abmahnung bekommt und dann nach der zweiten oder dritten Abmahnung das Internet gekappt bekommt. Und das finde ich eigentlich eine unverschämte Forderung, dass man halt junge Menschen quasi von der Kommunikation ausschließt, weil sie Kultur getauscht haben.
Deswegen würde ich jetzt das letzte Wort nochmal in die große weite Welt geben, und zwar zu Christian aus Potsdam. Wir haben jetzt zwei Stunden lang über Pro- und Kontra Filesharing gesprochen. Wir haben viele technische und juristische Details angemerkt. Hans aus Leipzig hat eben gerade sehr schön gesagt, Filesharing, ja, alles ganz gut und schön. Es gibt andere Alternativen, die viel besser sind, wie zum Beispiel jamendo.com. Auch Christian möchte eine Alternative anbringen. Hallo Christian.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren das auch mal ausprobiert und also einige Dateien runtergezogen. Und im Endeffekt fühlt das dann darin, dass ich mir einfach die CDs gekauft habe, weil das bringt es nicht. Und in der letzten Zeit war halt das Problem, dass man dann halt irgendwas sucht, was dann jeder hat, wartet zwei Wochen und hat dann keine Lust mehr. Hat mir auch erklärt, dass man dann auch schon bei halbem MP3s quasi schon was auf den Deckel kriegen kann. Ich habe es dann einfach sein gelassen. Aber halt mit der heftigeren Nutzung von Linux, was ich ja so nebenbei noch in der Uni mit benutze, braucht man die ja eigentlich wieder. Und da ist es ganz sinnvoll, dass man die P2P Netzwerke hat, weil man da richtig tolle Sachen so fürs Programm runterladen kann. Dann haben wir auch angefangen uns mit Open Source zu beschäftigen und ein paar Spiele zu suchen. Und die kann man ja alle darüber downloaden, ohne sich irgendwie vor irgendwem fürchten zu müssen. Und ja, dafür kann man es eigentlich ganz gut benutzen. Und da gibt es auch ganz nette Spielchen. Man muss nur ein bisschen suchen. Und da macht sich auch der Torrent ganz gut. Und ich nehme meistens die MyTorrent, weil der ist nicht so groß. Hat, glaube ich, nur zwei Megabytes. Passt auf jeden USB-Stick und kann man mitnehmen. Und läuft ganz gut. Und man muss sich da vor allem keine Sorgen machen, dass man das von der Firma erwischt wird.
Genau, also Tauschbörsen generell nicht nur für illegales Filesharing, sondern auch vorwiegend eigentlich vor allem BitTorrent. War wirklich ursprünglich auch gedacht dafür. Behaupte ich einfach mal so. Stell ich mal in den Raum und sag, BitTorrent ist eigentlich genau ein tolles Medium, ein tolles System, um wirklich große Mengen an Daten wie zum Beispiel CD-Images, also komplette DVDs mit Installationen, mit Software, vor allem mit freier Software natürlich und freier Musik und freien Filmen im Netz zu verbreiten. Tauschbörsen sind gut.
Und damit nehme ich jetzt, das war ein wunderbares Schlusswort, und damit nehme ich jetzt den Pfaden in die Hand und sage nochmal zu Christian, danke für den Anruf und dein Hinweis zum Schluss, wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, sich mit Open Source und Linux beschäftigt, findet man neue Möglichkeiten, wie man BitTorrent nutzen kann und der Rest der Welt der Satik nehme einfach jetzt meinen Rechner, werfe den Anwalt zu faulen, meine MP3s zu beschriften. Freunde, da braucht ihr euch nicht wundern, wenn ihr früher oder später irgendwann mal Post von einem Anwalt bekommt. Was dann passiert, darüber könnt ihr euch mit dem Anwalt eures Vertrauens unterhalten. Das auf jeden Fall war Chaosradio 133 mit Markus Becke da. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Mit Frank Rosengardt, herzlichen Dank. Genau, und wenn ihr Fragen habt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Und wenn ihr noch mehr Technik und Nerdkram machen wollt, Chaosradio Express, alles unter chaosradio.ccc.de Genau, jetzt geht's weiter mit dem Night Flight und André Langenfeld. Wir machen Tschüss für heute und sagen bis morgen oder so.